Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt. Äh mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff.
Ja und das hier ist die hundertfünfte Ausgabe von UKW vom 11. Oktober.
20, 2undzwanzig und ja, wenig überraschend geht's heute wieder um die Ukraine, das heißt, ich begrüße Pavel, hallo Pavel.
Denn äh ja nach wie vor ist die allgemeine Aktivität im Krieg recht hoch und äh ist uns wichtig ein paar Aspekte hier zeitnah zu besprechen.
Und ja, heute wollen wir hm uns mal allgemein mit
der Situation Russlands beschäftigen, die jetzt glaube ich für die ganz Ereignisse nicht ganz unerheblich ist.
Dann wollen wir natürlich über die Explosion auf der Kerchbrücke äh sprechen, die natürlich in aller Munde ist und natürlich auch die jetzt auch zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo wir das aufnehmen, noch
anhaltenden Cruismithall Angriffe auf die Ukraine.
Und danach nochmal auf die Fortschritte bei den beiden offensiven der Ukraine gegen Russland in ähm Casson und auch in Luhansk sprechen.
Denke, eine Rarativ-Offensive in dem Sinne gibt's jetzt nicht mehr. Ist zwar noch nicht komplett befreit, aber schon so gut wie und jetzt geht's halt dort in die nächste Phase.
Dann wollen wir noch ein wenig über ja die Situation der Waffentechnik, was da gerade so geliefert wird, was so zum Einsatz kommt in der Ukraine äh sprechen ja und ähm.
Dann noch einen Ausblick wagen. Genau. Fangen wir an mit Russland.
Warum? Weil glaube ich es nicht ganz unerheb,
ist mal so nochmal so auf diese Gesellschaft und auch die politische Situation in Russland zu schauen und das alles ein bisschen einsortieren zu können, was eigentlich Putin derzeit zu welcher Maßnahme drängt
Wir hatten ja jetzt diese ganze Mobilisierung und auch diese Mobilisierung erschienen ja auch schon etwas zu sein.
Putin so lange wie möglich herauszögern wollte.
Und sich dann aber doch dazu genötigt sah es zu machen, wenngleich viele jetzt der Meinung sind, das käme ja auch viel zu spät.
Zumindest um seine äh Ziele zu erreichen beziehungsweise um diese offensiven der Ukraine zurückzuschlagen. Da haben die sich also so oder so verkalkuliert wie mit diesem ganzen Krieg eigentlich.
Die Frage ist halt immer nur, wer ist eigentlich jetzt die treibende Kraft an dieser Stelle?
Und es gibt halt so ein paar Gruppen, die zwar immer wieder Erwähnung finden, aber die durchaus so ihre Bedeutung haben in diesem ganzen Spiel.
Die kann man mal benennen. Ähm grundsätzlich teilt sich ja so
Die russische Gesellschaft so in drei Lager auf, da gibt's halt auf der einen Seite so die Horks, also die, die irgendwie diesen Krieg bejubeln und denen's irgendwie alles nicht kriegerisch genug sein kann, dann gibt's halt so die aufgeklärte,
in Anführungsstrichen Linke kriegsfeindliche Teil der Gesellschaft, den's natürlich immer schon gegeben hat, aber der wahrscheinlich zu diesem Zeitpunkt das Land auch schon weitgehend verlassen hat und die halt auch einfach, weil
Putin und die letzten 20 Jahre damit verbracht hat, die auch kategorisch Schritt für Schritt äh aus dem
aus dem gesellschaftlichen Leben auszuschließen, einfach gar nicht mehr viel äh Kraft hat irgendetwas zu bewirken.
Ja und dann eben so die Dritte, die große Gruppe, ne und die,
entpolitisierte, egal Bevölkerung, die äh eigentlich lieber wegschaut und äh mir doch egal, habe ich da nix mit zu tun, lass mal den Putin machen, Hauptsache ich kann hier irgendwie shoppen gehen,
die aber jetzt eben von dieser ganzen Mobilisierung total.
Angepisst ist, weil sie natürlich jetzt sehen, dass sie jetzt selber mit in diesen Konflikt reingezogen werden, auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise.
Und in diesem rechten Lager in diesem Militär Kriegsjubillager gibt's natürlich auch verschiedenste.
Gruppen, die man vielleicht mal auseinanderhalten muss und interessanterweise ist eigentlich kleiner Teil davon auch im Internet unterwegs.
Diese
Szene, die natürlich diesen ganzen Krieg begleiten, so wie es natürlich viele Leute im Netz gibt, die das aus der ukrainischen Perspektive betrachten, gibt's das natürlich auch äh aus russischer Perspektive
deren Einfluss scheint so gering auch gar nicht zu sein. Ähm gab jetzt, glaube ich, auch so ein Event, wo Putin die sogar eingeladen hat.
Ja, um sie da so ein bisschen, weiß ich nicht, zu beschwichtigen oder einzulullen oder äh was auch immer da der Inhalt dieses Treffens gewesen sein mag.
Aber ähm es gibt dann eben auch noch so diese Veteranen.
Also ich sage mal so, die alten Kriegsbegeisterten und natürlich auch solche Power-Hauses rund um diese Wagner-Gruppe. Wir hatten ja diesen.
Nochmal äh.
Regurien, ne? So einer äh
ja eigentlich der so in dieses Putinlager zu zählen ist so ein Milliardär, der eben diese Wagner-Truppe aufgestellt hat
die so ein bisschen die Drecksarbeit äh immer verrichtet in den ganzen Konflikten, die Russland hm in den letzten Jahren so vom Damm gebrochen hat.
Ja und da scheint wohl eine echte Bedrohung
drinnen zu stecken für Putin, weil die halt sozusagen noch hockischer sind als er schon, denen's alles nicht äh krass genug sein kann, die diese ganze
denke diese ganze imperialistische Denke Russlands vollständig in sich aufgesogen hat und quasi jetzt auch
Putin dazu drängen eben jetzt noch aktiver zu werden und die potenziell ja auch als die Leute gelten, die ihnen.
Gegebenenfalls vom Thron stoßen könnten, weil sie eigentlich die einzigen sind, die äh die entsprechende Macht auch haben.
Teilweise eben auch eine militärische Macht, weil sie eben mit in diesen ganzen Sicherheitsapparat reinragen, der letzten Endes.
Eigentliche Machtbasis von Putin ist. Also nicht die politische Machtbasis, sondern eben diese.
Konkrete Machtbasis der Sicherheitsapparat, der eben dafür sorgt, dass äh alle kleingehalten werden.
Einschließlich des Militärs, was eben gar nicht so eine dominante Rolle spielt in Russland, sondern.
Militär, das sind halt eigentlich so ein bisschen die Deppen. Ja, die müssen die Kriege führen. Da werden die Leute verheizt.
Aber trotzdem hat die Armee selbst gar nicht so einen großen Status in diesem ganzen System.
Sondern wird eben auch entsprechend kleingehalten und äh hat nicht unbedingt jetzt
Möglichkeit, hier groß ähm irgendetwas kippen zu lassen in der Gesellschaft. Man will ja von so einem typischen militärischen Coup vielleicht träumen. Das ist aber eher unwahrscheinlich.
Weil's eben diesen Sicherheitsapparat gibt, der nochmal separat davon ist.
Ja, daneben gibt's halt Innenministeriumstruppen Ommern und dann die Nationalgarde
die da eine Rolle spielt und dann äh natürlich der FSB, äh der da als Geheimdienst, als Auslands äh Geheimdienst
äh einem auch noch äh mitmischt und äh ja dann, wie du schon erwähntest, äh äh Wagner Gruppe.
Ähm zu den, ich sage mal, Rechten oder zu den nationalistischen äh
Gruppen ist aber noch äh ein interessantes Ding zu sagen, nämlich hm.
Dass sie halt auch keine Lösung
haben für das ganze Problem. Das sieht wohl auch das Russische Establishment so ein bisschen. Das heißt, äh die können zwar auf der einen Seite jetzt Druck machen
Aber die sind wohl eben auch nicht so.
Stark und haben jetzt auch nicht wirklich eine Idee, dass sie in der Lage wären äh jetzt.
Ja, die Macht dort äh zu übernehmen, sondern diese Gruppen das ist halt wohl schon so ein bisschen austariert und was dann immer auch passieren sollte, wenn Putin äh.
Äh äh äh weg ist oder oder in diesem in diesem äh äh Prozess äh äh wäre, dass die sich dann wahrscheinlich auf
irgendwie eine Kompromissfigur als Nachfolger einigen äh äh müssten, dass da keine Seite
genug ist. Äh irgendwie quasi ihren äh Kandidaten dann dann durchzubringen. Das ist so eine Einschätzung unter anderem von,
Putins äh langjährigen Redenschreiber der 22 Jahre mit ihnen zusammengearbeitet hat.
Also äh das ist da aber auch äh jetzt schon Machtkämpfe gibt, das lässt sich ja schon daran festmachen, wie am laufenden Meter auch die Oberkommandierenden dieses Kriegs ausgetauscht werden.
Hatte äh Russland am Anfang, glaube ich, mit drei oder vier verschiedenen separat kämpfenden äh Truppen den Krieg gestartet,
in einzelnen Kampfbereichen, also da im Norden die Kiew Geschichte, die Kämpfe im Donbass, der Angriff auf äh
Mario Pohl, äh
und eben auch Ressourcen. Das waren alles so unterschiedliche Generäle, die das äh kommandiert haben ohne große Abstimmungen untereinander. Dann wurde es irgendwann wieder zusammengefasst. Ich mir fallen jetzt diese ganzen Namen nicht ein. Ich habe einfach so ein schlechtes Gefühl für russische Namen.
Die Russen haben alle paar Monate irgendwie äh ihre Befehlshaber ausgewechselt und irgendwie äh einen neuen
Oberbefehlshaber eingesetzt, der dann aber wie sich rausstellte dann doch nicht den Oberbefehl hatte. Also insofern ist äh.
Das Interessanteste äh sicherlich äh an diesem neuen General sein angeblicher Spitzname, so der äh wo ich nicht weiß, ob das wirklich stimmt, ob wirklich Militär ist ihn so genannt haben oder.
Ob das nicht äh von der
einfach eine Erfindung der russischen Propaganda ist, also kolportiert wurde, dass wohl irgendwie in der
äh so, dass das angeblich irgendwie Leute ihn general
Armageddon äh nennen wir Captain Armageddon oder ich weiß es nicht äh und ich dachte mir dann äh nur äh ja unsere Medien haben sich natürlich auch gleich sofort drauf gestürzt so
oh mein Gott und äh äh wo der nicht überall gekämpft hat und soll soll ein brutaler Hardliner.
Sein, der dann auch bei den Rechten irgendwie angeblich auf äh Begeisterung gestoßen ist, so nach dem Motto, jawoll, jetzt.
Geht's endlich los. Ja, ich weiß nur nicht, ob ich
ähm ja als äh jetzt seriöser General äh gerne mit dem Spitznamen General Armageddon äh äh rum
laufen würde, also besonders seriös klingt das nicht, vor allen Dingen ich meine Armageddon, das ist auch sozusagen die letzte Schlacht so ja was ist was so so wollen sie jetzt damit signalisieren äh treten sie jetzt zur zur letzten
Schlacht an oder was und ähm ja mhm also die Ukrainer äh rechnen nicht damit, dass,
sich irgendwas ändert dadurch, weil äh einfach die Einschätzung ist, dass russische Militär ist.
Auf so vielen Ebenen, so disfunktional, also äh
dann auch meine Einschätzung war, okay äh wenn der gute Mann, der auch so unkonventionelle Ideen und so bekannt ist, der muss jetzt also nur.
Sagen erstmal sich wirklich den Oberbefehl verschaffen dann das Kommunikationsproblem lösen, das Logistikproblem, die Disziplin äh äh Probleme und äh,
Ja äh Ausbildungsprobleme hm,
und dann vielleicht äh sage ich mal, wenn er das dann alles gelöst hat so denn vielleicht in einem halben Jahr oder so könnte das dann die Wände bringen. So ist es
wäre meine Einschätzung, also mit anderen Worten, da ist wieder ja viel, viel Wind und wahrscheinlich wenig dahinter.
Im Gegensatz zur Ukraine, wo alles sehr geordnet läuft. Dort ist Valerie äh Salusny der Führer.
Ukrainischen Streitkräfte und macht ja einen sehr,
besonnenen und äh kompetenten Eindruck ist äh auf jeden Fall auch schon auf Volksheldstatus ähm gekommen, denke ich mal, in der Ukraine und führt ja, dass diese gesamte Verteidigung einfach,
sehr klug und sehr pfiffig, wie wir da äh nachher auch noch besprechen werden.
Ja also die Auswirkungen der Mobilisierung hatten wir ja hier auch schon mal.
Angesprochen. Die hängen natürlich jetzt damit zusammen. Jetzt äh wurde also beschlossen, alles muss mobilisiert werden und dass das nicht so richtig gut läuft, das das zeichnet sich jetzt schon seit längerem ab und es hat sich jetzt eigentlich auch in der letzten Woche
meiner Auffassung nach wenig ergeben, wo man denken könnte, da würde sich äh auch nur mittelfristig irgendetwas dran.
Verbessern. Viele Dinge, die vorhergesagt wurden, sind auch schon eingetreten. Die Leute bekommen halt,
kaum Ausrüstung, bekommen äh wenig Training. Viele werden nach wenigen Tagen schon an die Front geschickt und sind dann irgendwie ein paar Tage später auch entweder tot oder schon in Gefangenschaft.
Ähm und das hat natürlich auch extreme Auswirkungen auf Russland.
Als solches, ne? Wir hatten ja letztes Mal schon diese Zahl genannt, die so ein bisschen im Raum steht, die ich jetzt nicht so richtig belegen kann, aber es gibt halt enorm.
Hohe Flüchtlingszahlen, die die einzelnen umliegenden Länder melden und äh man kann das jetzt eben so ausgehen, dass es mindestens wohl eine halbe Million ist, vielleicht sogar schon deutlich mehr.
Und das ist natürlich äh für Russland dreifach hart.
Ja bis zu sogar also bis zu 700.000 im Ausland Inseln ins Ausland äh gegangen. Also russische Männer ähm aber das,
noch nicht mal das Schlimmste wahrscheinlich kommt dann auch noch auf jeden, der ins Ausland geht, kommen dann noch zwei oder drei, die
einfach sich
Russland verstecken vor der Rekrutierung, also äh sprich irgendwie aufs Land gegangen sind oder sich bei Verwandten äh irgendwo äh unterkommen, bloß nicht an der offiziellen Meldeadresse und weil äh.
Eben die Russen auch am Arbeitsplatz äh ja rekrutieren. Ähm.
Ähm führt das dazu, dass diese Leute natürlich auch alle ihre Arbeit fernbleiben und sodass äh man vielleicht davon ausgehen kann, dass es die
ineffizienteste Mobilisierung aller Zeiten ist, weil normalerweise ist ja schon ein Problem, wenn du eine Person
mobilisierst, die dann nicht mehr äh dem Arbeitsmarkt.
Zur Verfügung steht und nicht mehr für die Produktion da ist, aber wenn für jeden, den du ziehst, drei, fünf, sieben Leute dem Arbeitsplatz fernbleiben, ja,
dann ist es einfach mal äh eine komplette äh wirtschaftliche Katastrophe und es gibt Schätzungen, dass wir sagen.
Diese Auswirkungen der Mobilisierung wohl wirtschaftlich katastrophaler äh sind als die ganzen Sanktionen zusammengenommen. Also dass die äh
Die Wirtschaft stärker schrumpfen lassen äh werden ähm ja als als die Sanktionen und zwar natürlich auch relativ schnell und.
Hm und das andere Problem ist, dass offensichtlich,
aus Einfachheit äh sind auch die Rekrutierer in Firmen reingegangen und haben dort dann die halbe Belegschaft.
Eingezogen.
Und ähm was dann dazu geführt hat, dass die andere Hälfte der der Belegschaft äh sich dann aus dem Staub gemacht hat, was dann eben ja wohl eine Reihe von Unternehmen einfach mal.
Komplett kaputt hinterlässt so und darunter sind dann natürlich aber auch Unternehmen
die jetzt für die Rüstungsproduktion wichtig sind, weil wir denken, werden ja eigentlich so so dumm sein, aber um das zu vermeiden, müsstest du halt genau wissen, wie denn eigentlich dein Supply Chain
aussieht um bestimmte Waffen oder Rüstungsgüter zu bauen und die sind ja je je.
Moderner die Waffen umso komplexer, also gerade bei Panzern und so hm kann man das halt kaum
nachvollziehen, wer was genau zuliefert, sodass ich davon ausgehe, dass sie auch noch mal.
Äh quasi ihren militärischen Supply Chain massiv geschädigt haben, weil sie keine Möglichkeit haben so richtig jetzt äh Rüstungswichtige von Rüstungs
unwichtigen äh äh Produktionsstätten zu unterscheiden, wenn du dir die halt die gesamte Lieferkette anschaust.
Das sind ja nicht nur Auswirkungen auf ja, die die eigene Rüstungsproduktion, auf die sie jetzt in zunehmendem Maße,
sind, um überhaupt da ihren Flow zu erhalten, ähm sondern sind ja auch eine Rüstungsexport
Nation und die sehe ich jetzt natürlich auch extrem in Gefahr. Also so Länder wie Indien werden sich das jetzt glaube ich zwei-, dreimal überlegen
Ob sie jetzt diese ganzen Geräte noch kaufen sollen, die einerseits vermutlich kaum lieferbar sind, die sich technisch wahrscheinlich auch auf absehbare Zeit nicht nennenswert weiterentwickeln werden und darüber hinaus ja jetzt auch in den Ukrainekrieg nicht gerade bewiesen haben, dass sie besonders gut funktionieren würden.
Ja, also das ist sicherlich ja das ist ein Problem, das wahrscheinlich ihr Exportmarkt
äh für für Waffen aus verschiedensten äh Gründen grade zusammenbricht, unter anderem, weil sie auch erst mal selber äh sicherlich brauchen, bevor sie die die exportieren.
Aber es geht halt noch äh weiter. Man befürchtet eben das auch, weil grade so viel Landbevölkerung rekrutiert worden ist, dass dort dann jetzt äh ja
das mit der Landwirtschaft ist, die Landwirtschaftliche Produktion, Nahrungsmittel
auch leiden könnte plus natürlich Infrastruktur, weil sie knapp sind an Fahrern an der Front, haben sie wohl auch besonders viele Fahrer
äh irgendwie versucht zu rekrutieren, die dann natürlich jetzt auf dem Land fehlen, um was weiß ich, Busse zu fahren oder,
LKW ja die gesamte Versorgung äh tatsächlich äh äh könnte jetzt in in Teilen des Landes auch einfach gefährdet sein. Ähm und
könnte sich eben auch jetzt sehr, sehr schnell äh auswirken, weil äh ja
sie eben so chaotisch und überhastet und planlos vorgegangen sind, aber ein weiterer Aspekt
ähm neben dem ja, ich sage mal den den wirtschaftlichen.
Auswirkungen sind halt die psychologischen Auswirkungen der Mobilisierung.
Und äh was eben auch dumm war, war äh normalerweise rekrutierst du halt junge Leute so.
Ja äh siebzehn, achtzehn, neunzehn, 20 bis 27 offiziell so aus verschiedensten
gründen, so unter anderem auch Belastbarkeit und die kannst du schneller trainieren und die sind in der Regel gesünder und.
Noch keine Familien.
Ja haben keine Familien, mucken nicht so auf und fehlen noch nicht so in der Wirtschaft. Äh so und
und die Älteren äh schicken dann halt erstmal die Jungen in den Krieg. Aber Putin hat halt gleich so mit seiner Teilmobilisierung alles zwischen 18 und
sechzig erstmal Mobilisiert und als sich dann rausstellte, dass auch egal ist, ob man militärische Erfahrung hat oder nicht, hat sich praktisch die gesamte männliche Bevölkerung
plötzlich potenziell an der Front gesehen, was eben auch zu diesen diesen hohen äh äh Fluchtzahlen beigetragen hat. Plus.
Ja, dass äh durch diese Mobilisierung jetzt auch dieser Deal mit der, sage mal, 50 bis 60 Prozent Gruppe
gebrochen wurde, die da so eher neutral ist oder die die eher lieber auf der Couch äh.
Sitzt und ähm für die das Ganze irgendwie ja ein weiterer, ich nenne es mal Auslandseinsatz war ungefähr so, weiß ich nicht, wie bei uns.
Der deutsche Auslandseinsatz in Afghanistan, so vielleicht diese diese Kategorie jetzt nix was jetzt
Auswirkungen auf das tägliche Leben.
Wirklich hat, aber das hat sich jetzt natürlich irgendwie äh gravierend geändert und äh dieser.
Deal ähm so plötzlich ist der ist jetzt gebrochen, plötzlich ist der Krieg.
Ja äh auf die Couch gekommen und äh droht äh die Leute irgendwie jetzt von der Couch zu werfen und sie haben halt
riesige Probleme grade so die die Realität
irgendwie an sich ranzulassen. Ja äh und.
Das wird wohl auch noch eine Weile dauern, bis bis sie.
Wirklich aufgewacht sind und wirklich allgemein verstanden haben, was denn da in der Ukraine passiert. Hm für viele äh dieser Russen äh die die glauben, die Ukraine hätte Russland angegriffen.
Ja so und Russland müsste sich jetzt wehren, also das äh ja und ähm.
Wenn äh gibt, gibt's einen so einen schönen Kanal, auch 1420 heißt er, er läuft halt immer rum und fragt dann Leute auf der Straße, was sie denn so zu bestimmten Fragen denken und da siehst du in einen.
Interessantes Interview mit einem, der so die ganze Zeit ja und äh äh Russland und äh klar und wir müssen irgendwie Ukraine äh hat uns irgendwie angegriffen und jetzt müssen wir uns verteidigen und.
So ähm und dann fragt halt der Interviewer so nach, na ja ähm wieso hat
die Ukraine jetzt uns angegriffen, wo wir Atomwaffen haben so hm und dann merkst du so wie er anfängt so,
zu denken, wirklich schwer zu denken und irgendwie plötzlich so so geht ihm so halb äh also geht ihm auf, dass irgendwie stimmt was. Eine Bibi
so es scheint er scheint ihm plötzlich offensichtlich unplausibel, dass die Idee, dass sie äh
schwache Ukraine jetzt das große, mächtige Russland angreifen könnte. So siehst denn wirklich, wie er irgendwie dann.
Ähm ja wie heißt es so schön ähm.
Äh ja kognitive Dissonanz, wie bei ihm unangenehme, kognitive Dissonanz einsetzt und das ist, glaube ich, bei vielen
Russen gerade so, dass sie versucht, neben kognitive Distonanz zu vermeiden, die eben sehr schmerzhaft ist, aber äh ja, Blatt Wechsler beschrieb das so, dass sie alle
quasi wie wie nach einem Kater, nach einem großen jetzt da liegen und irgendwie so morgens
ein Auge aufmachen und irgendwie die Realität sehen und das dann erstmal gleich wieder zumachen und also ja und dann
Aber können sie halt doch äh müssten sie halt doch wieder irgendwie gucken und so beschreibt er in etwa den den Prozess wie die Russen sich jetzt langsam vielleicht
mehr an die Realität rantasten dessen dessen was was passiert, was da gerade auf sie äh eingebrochen ist und,
Das ist sozusagen jetzt in in etwa der der Stand, was Sie, was die Bevölkerung äh angeht und was die Eliten angeht.
Es aber durch die Mobilisierung quasi auch eine neue Situation entstanden.
Und zwar ähm,
sind jetzt die Ziele von Putin nicht mehr deckungsgleich
mit den Zielen der Elite und der Oligarchen um ihn herum. Also äh es ist jetzt klar, es.
Jetzt nach diesem Schritt irgendwie keinen Weg zurück, aber sie hätten halt schon
gerne, bin halt schon gerne wieder irgendwann mal ins Ausland reisen und vielleicht
dann auch wieder irgendwie ihre Yachten benutzen beziehungsweise die nicht Oligarchen würden einfach gerne auch weiterleben und äh weiter gut leben.
Ja und äh das hat jetzt aber einen Punkt erreicht, wo die das Gefühl haben, okay, da,
Wo Putin das Land jetzt hinführt, dass es.
Nicht da, wo wir sein wollen, so und das ist jetzt wie gesagt das das Problem. Nur gibt es eben auch noch.
Gesagt niemanden, der da jetzt dem sie auch eine bessere Lösung zutrauen im im Moment. Aber
der Punkt äh könnte halt spätestens kommen, wenn irgendwie noch weitere Niederlagen oder pushes erfolgen und wenn das, was Putin jetzt tut, äh keine
erfolgreiche Wende im Krieg bringt, was eben sehr wahrscheinlich ist. So dann kann das eben auch sehr schnell gehen. In Russland, dass sich da was ändert.
Ja und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, auch Einschätzung von diesem Redenschreiber ist okay, wenn.
Den Putin jetzt gehen würde oder gegangen äh würde, ob denn dann der Nachfolger eher noch.
Sein würde oder eher versuchen würde einen Kompromiss zu finden und seine Einschätzung war äh dass wahrscheinlich ein Nachfolger.
Ihr,
ja ich sage mal nicht schlimmer wäre als als Putin, sondern tendenziell gemäßigt da, aber was dann natürlich passiert, ist ähm.
Dass es dann natürlich in dem Moment,
auch äh komplett äh zu einem Zusammenbruch äh kommen kann, weil der Nachfolger vielleicht nicht in der Lage ist äh so die Loyalität,
äh wirklich dann aller äh zu halten und wirklich die Kontrolle zu halten. Das ist so ein bisschen das Szenario, was da.
Ähm oder ein ein wahrscheinliches Szenario, was da in Russland dann dann passieren könnte.
Ja ja dass Russland ähm einfach ein merkwürdiges Land ist in mancherlei äh Hinsicht oder vor allem auch ein Land der totalen Extreme.
Hat auch noch mal ein interessanter Schritt von diesem äh Kamilgalev, der ja schon seit
Anfang des Krieges mit seinen langen Fritz auf Twitter immer wieder super interessante Einblicke so in die russische äh Seele und die ganzen historischen Zusammenhänge äh et cetera bietet. Hat er nochmal geliefert
Äh und zwar ist er nochmal auf diese Sache mit ähm dem Tweet von Elon Musk eingegangen.
Wir hatten da ja auch letzte Woche schon drüber gesprochen, dass äh ja dass das alles so ein bisschen merkwürdig wirkt. Warum jetzt
gerechnet, Elon Musk sich zu Wort meldet. Gut, der meldet sich zu allen möglichen äh zu Wort. Insofern überrascht es vielleicht jetzt nicht, aber warum ausgerechnet jetzt noch in dieser Situation, zumal er bisher
durch äh sein Engagement äh mit Darling et cetera so diesen Nimbus äh hatte des wohlmeinenden Amerikaners, der in irgendeiner Form hier auch noch
vielleicht positiv zum Gesamtgeschehen beitragen kann, aber dann eben mit diesem Tweet aufkam mit, na ja, man könnte doch jetzt mal hier irgendwie einen Deal,
Putin äh finden und das wäre doch alles viel schöner.
Und die Perspektive, die er aufgemacht hat, die fand ich sehr interessant. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie diesen Schritt gelesen hast. Ähm,
dass er äh also er erklärt sozusagen erstmal das Feld der Wirtschaft auf einem wieder mit einem interessanten Blickwinkel, den ich so noch nie eingenommen habe.
Dass er nämlich die Wirtschaft in so einen nicht gewalttätigen und einen gewalttätigen Teil aufsplittet.
Der einfach real ist und sagt, dass die Situation halt in USA eben ganz äh anders ist, denn dort kannst du als Innovator.
Hm eigentlich im Wesentlichen tun, was du willst. Du lebst in einer Gesellschaft, die ich soweit beschützt.
Durch den Staat, durch die Polizei, et cetera dass du äh im Wesentlichen so dann Dingen nachgehen kannst und in Ruhe äh arbeiten kannst, mal salopp formuliert.
Und gibt als Beispiel vor allem diese furchtbaren Kryptoszene äh herbei, nicht weil er,
irgendwie toll findet dieses Auftreten dieser ganzen Kryptobros für so absurd krass äh hält, ne.
Permanent mit ihrem Reichtum und mit dem, was sie tun äh angeben und das irgendwie überall in Tweets, in YouTube-Videos,
wo auch immer in allen möglichen News-Outlets von sich geben und sich selber die ganze Zeit dafür feiern.
Was sie doch da alles tolles unternehmen würden.
Und lenkt dann sozusagen den Blick mal auf Russland, wo natürlich, wie wir wissen, auch eine ganze Menge Leute mit Kryptogeld unterwegs sind, aber wo niemand.
In der Öffentlichkeit damit groß hausieren gehen würde. Warum? Weil das wirtschaftliche Investment eben in Russland mitnichten so ist
man dort in irgendeiner Form vor etwas geschützt ist. Ich glaube, wir hatten das auch ganz zu Anfang hier auch schon mal grob diskutiert, die gesamte Lage
der der Wirtschaft in äh Russland im Allgemeinen und wie auch durch dieses Regime hm das,
dort verschoben wird, dass insbesondere die Leute, die jetzt, sagen wir mal, intellektuell äh nicht unbedingt äh ganz vorne stehen äh und als besondere Innovatoren,
gelten halt dort Einfluss haben weil sie einfach von Putin mit relativ einfach zu führenden Unternehmen äh vertraut betraut werden oder
gelassen werden, ne. Die machen dann fördern dann halt Öl und Gas und plündern die Ressourcen und Kohle et cetera und das sind halt alles so Industrien.
Nicht mehr viel erfinden. Da muss man eigentlich nur diesen Betrieb organisieren, das Zeug rausholen, weiterverkaufen, fertig.
Während jetzt Leute, die eben so zum Beispiel im Computerbereich arbeiten oder Hochtechnologie machen
ähm sehr viel kleiner gehalten werden, weil
die Leute viel zu intelligent sind, viel zu pfiffig sind, viel zu viel Einblick haben, sich viel zu viel Gedanken machen und dementsprechend dann in der Gesellschaft auch kleingehalten werden. Was natürlich dann dazu führt, dass diese Innovation so,
in Russland nicht stattfinden kann, nicht diesen Raum, nicht diesen Freiraum hat. Und als extremes Beispiel hat er dann.
Irgendwie einen Fall äh hervorgeholt, den fand ich einfach wirklich krass. Da ist irgendwie im letzten Jahr bei Sankt Petersburg irgendwie so ein.
Haus entdeckt worden.
Ähm das äh so schon so so eine so eine leichte Ruine äh war und das gehörte so im ehemaligen Businessman, der äh gestorben ist und dann wurde entdeckt, dass ich unter diesem Haus.
Ein Gefängnis befindet. Also ein Bunker quasi, der aber,
nicht einfach nur so ein Bunker ist, um sich vor irgendwas zu schützen, sondern der also nicht nur wie ein Gefängnis.
Wirkte, sondern auch genauso aussah wie Gefängnisse in Russland eben aussehen. Und das war offensichtlich so eine.
Eine Simulation, wo dann Leute.
Von denen man wusste, dass sie irgendwie Geld haben, wie zum Beispiel Leuten, die in Krypto unterwegs sind, von denen man ja im Prinzip nicht sehr viel mehr äh wissen musste als ein Passwort und dann hatte man ihr Geld.
Ah
Die dann gekidnappt wurden, da reingesteckt wurden und das Gefühl hatten, sie wären jetzt in einem richtigen Gefängnis gelandet.
Und dann sozusagen solange dort äh traktiert wurden und ohne Aussicht auf äh Verlassen dieser Situation gelassen wurden.
Bis sie dann halt äh ihre Geheimnisse auch äh rausgerückt haben, dann aber trotzdem gekillt wurden. Und dieses ganze.
Enviamond sozusagen in Russland, wo du einfach in so einer permanenten Bedrohung bist von von Weilen
Entrepreneurs äh ja also Unternehmern, die sozusagen überhaupt nicht in irgendeiner Form jetzt vom Staat und vom Gesellschaftssystem daran gehindert werden, diese Gewalt auszuüben, die haben natürlich dann diese Dominanz,
über solche Innovatoren. Während halt jemand wie Elon Musk sich einfach danach sehnt in so einem Enviam zu sein,
wo eben diese Gewalt nicht ist und deswegen diesen Wunsch hat,
nach dem Deal und dann ist es ihm auch irgendwie egal, weil der Deal muss gemacht werden und der Deal muss einfach mit den Leuten gemacht werden, die eben die Gewalt.
Gewaltmonopol haben und das ist halt in dem Fall Putin.
Und dieses ganze äh schreckliche Regime, was er aufgezogen hat und das ist so ein bisschen seine These, dass das sozusagen durchsickert bei diesem Kommentar,
dass er ja gerne irgendwie als Innovator irgendwie auch weltweit und auch in der Ukraine irgendwie einfach weitermachen kann mit seinem Ansatz an äh Wirtschaft und dann auf einmal dieser Wunsch nach einem Deal
auf einmal stärker wird als das Verständnis für die gesamt politischen Zusammenhänge.
Ich habe da ich habe da noch eine Geschichte aus
erste Hand die so ein bisschen dazu passt also und zwar bekannter von mir äh Russe,
äh hat mit ja hatte mit äh neun anderen Leuten haben die einen größeren Techno-Club.
Aufgebaut irgendwann so in den Zweitausendern in in in Russland, der auch richtig gut lief äh so.
Und ja dann kam irgendwann weiß ich nicht vor fünf, sechs Jahren oder so muss das gewesen sein.
Kam dann äh die.
Regierung, Staat und sagte ja, wenn ihr irgendwie weitermachen wollt, dann äh müsst ihr aber hier sozusagen politisch Propagandaprogramm mitfahren auf euren Veranstaltungen.
So ja also quasi keine Ahnung irgendwie so ein so ein irgendwelche Putinpropaganda dann äh dort.
Äh ja raustun und das äh haben da hatten sie aber dann irgendwie keinen Bock drauf und haben.
Gesagt, dass da der hat unser Publikum einfach keinen Bock drauf, sollen das. Ja und äh,
von den zehn Leuten äh sind
irgendwie sechs äh wohl äh verschwunden, also im im Gefängnis äh im Prinzip gelandet und der,
Freund, den haben sie auch äh irgendwann äh auf der Straße.
Haben irgendwelche Schläger ihn abgefangen und äh quasi eine Schlägerei inszeniert und dann kam die Polizei und dann wurde er erstmal ja.
Verhaftet und er hatte dann aber Glück, weil irgendwie sein Vater Connections hat zum Geheimdienst und ist dann geschafft hat,
ihn da wieder rauszukriegen und dann hat er sich halt nur aufgemacht und erstmal äh ja nach Deutschland.
Gesetzt, nachdem das passiert ist, so.
Also ja und den Club haben jetzt ja irgendwelche Leute äh jetzt übernommen, die da jetzt Propaganda machen äh.
So
Ja also das ist halt das Problem mit solchen unfreien Gesellschaften, dass die sich halt irgendwann an dieser Entwicklung auch komplett.
Selbst äh also an einer Weiterentwicklung auch selbst hindern so und ähm man kann viel klagen über die Zustände bei uns, aber in den Dimensionen spielt sich das nun wirklich nicht ab.
Gut, dann würde ich sagen, kommen wir mal zu dem Ereignis der Woche. Am ähm.
Am Sonntag. Morgens gab's auf einmal die Nachricht, dass es eine große Explosion gegeben hat auf der Kerch,
Brücke. Das ist die Brücke, die Russland und die Krim miteinander verbindet, ein Bauwerk, was recht neu ist, was 2018 erst eingeweiht wurde, das große Projekt, das große Bauprojekt von Putin und wie wir heute.
Natürlich wissen, vor allem getrieben durch diesen Wunsch äh diese militärische Offensive voranzutreiben, aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen der Anschluss an die russische Wirtschaft für die Krim um dort eben diesen
Landstrich auch entsprechend versorgen zu können, was vorher nur durch Fähren möglich gewesen ist, also Schiff, weil es gibt ja in dem Sinne keine Land,
Verbindung zu ähm Russland und ja,
lange wurde gerätselt, was äh dann dauert nun eigentlich tatsächlich passiert ist.
Aber ich denke, es lässt sich jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon ganz gut einschätzen, was dort vermutlich passiert ist. Vielleicht noch mal so zu dieser Struktur, dieser Brücke erst mal.
Es sind halt im Prinzip ist es so ein Doppelbauwerk, sind eigentlich zwei Brücken, die nebeneinander entlang führen, ein Autobrücke und eine Bahnbrücke.
Und das sind aber separate Strukturen, die auf separaten Pfeilern stehen. Auch ein anderes Höhenprofil teilweise auf äh
weisen und es gibt dann nochmal so eine Insel äh zwischen Russland und der äh Kriminsel.
Gerade gar nicht wie heißt. Äh die gehört auf jeden Fall auch noch zur Ukraine offiziell
Ja und dort wurde dann eben äh über diese Insel hinweg so ins zwei großen
diese Brücke geführt und in dem Abschnitt dann zwischen der kleinen Insel und der eigentlichen Krim dort ist dann eben auch eine,
Schifffahrtsstraße, also nochmal eine Bogenbrücke
untergebracht worden, wo die großen Schiffe durchfahren können. Man muss nämlich wissen, dass dieses Asofschemäer, was ja dort quasi endet in der Straße von Kersch, das ist ein relativ flaches Meer.
Und dementsprechend musste diese Brücke dort auch sehr hoch gebaut werden, da äh führt also die Bahnbrücke ist sowieso relativ hoch und die ähm Autobrücke, die geht dort noch mal extra nach oben, um dann eben zu diesem
äh zu diesem Bogen führen zu können, sodass dann dadrunter 50 Meter Platz ist, dass eben auch große Schiffe durchfahren können.
Ja und kurz vor diesem Bogen gab es diese Explosion morgens um sechs
Und es gibt zahlreiche Videoaufnahmen davon, teilweise eben von diesen Überwachungskameras, teilweise aus anderen Fahrzeugen, die zeigen ähm.
Was dort äh passiert ist und es eine extreme Explosion gewesen.
Die ähm ja Schaden zurückgelassen hat. Das sind dann von dieser Autobrücke, die selber eigentlich auch aus zwei Fahrspuren besteht, ist die eine Fahrspur ähm
extrem beschädigt vor. Das sind ja immer so einzelne Segmente, die so zwischen den Pfeilern ähm montiert sind. Davon ist eine durchgebrochen und ins Wasser gefallen. Daneben ist dann eine äh komplett
äh ins Wasser äh gekippt und zwei Segmente weiter ist dann auch nochmal eine aus diesen Halterungen gelöst worden. Da ist also sozusagen alles vorbei
die andere Fahrspur hat wohl auch ähm
Schaden davongezogen, ist aber im Prinzip noch befahrbar, wird aber derzeit nur mit PKWs befahren.
Weil man sich eben noch nicht traut dort äh schwere Fahrzeuge
fahren zu lassen. Das kann natürlich jetzt sein, dass zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo wir das jetzt hier aufnehmen, dass sich das schon wieder äh geändert hat, aber das war jetzt so ein bisschen der Stand von gestern und ähm ja und,
Was noch dazu kam ist, dass zum Zeitpunkt dieser Explosion, die offensichtlich eben auf dieser Fahrbahn stattgefunden hat, sich auch noch einen Zug mit
Tank äh wagen auf der Brücke befand, der dort entweder stand oder langsam fuhr und der durch diese Explosion
auch noch mit in Brand geraten ist und auch eine ganze Weile lang gebrannt hat. Ja und das war sozusagen die Situation, die die Welt dann vorgefunden hat.
Und äh alle fragten sich natürlich, was ist passiert.
Zwei äh Ergänzungen vielleicht noch einmal äh so zum zum Ort äh wo das passiert ist
äh das ist äh sagen relativ nah an der Krimseite und völkerrechtlich gesehen äh so im auf dem Hoheitsgebiet der Ukraine.
Nochmal wichtig ist zu sagen für die völkerrechtliche Beurteilung gesagt naja Ukraine na ja es ist irgendwie ein illegal auf unseren Territorium errichtetes Bauwerk und äh ja ich denke
äh das durchaus äh die Ukraine äh ich sage mal jetzt nicht deswegen aber im Rahmen sagen jetzt auch der Kriegshandlung, dass es sich schon auch durchaus um ein legitimes.
Militärisches äh Ziel gehandelt äh hat oder handelt, so die,
Zweite Sache ist noch, dass es zum wahrscheinlich wohl um sechs Uhr sieben
Ortszeit stattgefunden hat äh sodass relativ wenig Verkehr auf der Brücke.
War und das äh sagen nach russischen Angaben sagen drei
weitere Leute oder drei Leute dabei ums Leben gekommen äh sind äh neben dem Fahrer. Ähm.
Ja das das wollte ich noch ergänzen.
Genau. Da gab's natürlich schnell verschiedenste Thesen, was denn jetzt hier wohl explodiert sein könnte. Manche haben einen Angriff mit einer äh Cruise Missile in irgendeiner Form, also irgendeiner
Rakete äh fabulisiert, andere kamen mit Thesen auf wie, das könnte ja auch ein Boot gewesen sein, was unter der Brücke durchfuhr und explodiert ist,
äh die offizielle Darstellung Russlands war dann eben schnell, dass dort,
KW explodiert ist. Ich denke, nachdem.
Man sich jetzt sozusagen die Auswirkungen genauer hat anschauen können, Satellitenbilder, äh viele Fotos die von der Situation gemacht wurden, angucken konnte, lassen sich ähm
ein paar Dinge auf jeden Fall ausschließen. Es äh war unter Garantie kein Boot, weil man sieht ganz klar,
dass die Schlauchspuren dieser ganzen Explosion vor allem auf der Oberseite der Brücke ist und dass diese ganzen eingestürzten Segmente unten in der Form überhaupt keinerlei Explosionsspuren, also keine unmittelbaren Explosionsspuren aufweisen.
Dann äh ist auch die diese Geländer dieser Brücke sind entsprechend verbogen, sodass man schon sagen kann, da muss schon die Explosion wirklich,
oberhalb auf dieser Fahrbahn, in der Mitte der Fahrbahn stattgefunden haben.
Man kann sich auch angucken sozusagen, wo die umgeknickten Laternen hinzeigen, ja und die weisen eigentlich ziemlich genau dann auf das Zentrum dieses Explosionsorts und man kann dann,
auch äh sehen, dass dieser eine LKW sich wirklich genau an der Stelle
befunden hat äh wo dann auch die Schmausspuren äh äh sind und die umgeknickten Laternen hinzeigen.
Genau, aber es war vermutlich eben auch keine Rakete, weil es in dem Sinne kein Einschlagsgrater gibt, den es ja sonst hätte äh geben müssen. Also diese Brückenteile sind zwar durchgebrochen.
Aber äh typisch wäre eben gewesen, dass es dort eben in irgendeiner Form einen Einschlagsgrater hätte geben müssen, sodass es eben jetzt sehr danach aussieht.
Auch weitere Informationen, die rauskamen, bestätigen, dass dass hier wohl die Explosion von diesem LKW ausging, der.
Von der russischen Seite in Richtung der ukrainischen Seite fuhr. Das ist ja auch noch mal ein wichtiger Aspekt.
Und äh ja man hat dann auch Bilder sozusagen veröffentlicht äh die russische Seite von dem LKW an der Kontrollstelle, weil ähm.
Was ähm halt dazu kommt
ist, dass äh ja jeder einzelne LKW eben kontrolliert wird, bevor er auf die Brücke geht, muss halt seine Fahrzeuge zeigen. Da gibt es
vorne einen am Anfang der Brücke einen,
relativ ja, lange, große Kontrollstelle, hm kann man sich auch.
Angucken äh auf YouTube, äh so eine Fahrt über die über die Brücke, da sieht man das ganz ganz gut und am Ende dieser Kontrollstelle gibt es auch noch eine große Halle
wo dann auch unter anderem noch 'ne Durchleuchtungsanlage drin ist.
Und hm die Russen sagten aber der LKW sei nicht durchleuchtet worden, weil äh der Fahrer wohl unverdächtig schien und sie sagten ebenfalls, dass,
sagen die Spedition äh für die der Fahrer vor, der glaube ich aus Tadschikistan oder so.
Aserbaidschan oder so.
Aserbaidschan genau. Ähm.
Dass äh diese Ladung Sie auf einem Internetportal im Prinzip.
Äh was so Transporte vermittelt ähm geklickt haben äh sollen und hm,
ja was wenn das stimmt äh und ich habe da jetzt erstmal also klingt.
Zumindest plausibel, dass das Ganze.
Dann hat der Fahrer nichts davon gewusst äh so, das heißt äh ja ert auch die Explosion wohl eher nicht ausgelöst äh selbst und
aus meiner Sicht deuten zwei Dinge darauf hin, dass er davon nichts gewusst hat, dass eine ist ähm,
dass er eben unverdächtig schien äh an der Kontrollstelle und die ja die Kontrolleure.
Sind natürlich doch durchaus darauf geschult, irgendwie darauf zu achten und bestimmte Fragen zu stellen und ähm gut
es mag vielleicht Leute geben, die so cool sind, aber äh wenn du auf einer Mission bist, äh äh gleich lang die Brücke zu sprengen und.
Äh ja dein Leben zu beenden, dann kann ich mir vorstellen, ist es
eher schwierig cool zu bleiben so und äh sondern die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man irgendwas sich durch irgendwas verrät, ist dann relativ hoch, weshalb.
Geheimdienst geplant hat, äh sie.
Ihr sagt das in der Ladung, die Bomben in der Ladung verstecken würden und der Fahrer einfach,
ahnungslos ist. Dazu kommt noch, dass äh er auf der ganz auf der rechten Spur und,
relativ schnell gefahren ist so und.
Nicht verlangsamt hat oder nicht beschleunigt hat an der Stelle und ich könnte mir halt auch
vorstellen, äh ja, dass er entweder dann zum einen vielleicht versucht hätte, wäre auch kein Problem gewesen.
Den LKW anzuhalten, das Ding zu aktivieren und äh loszurennen, ja oder ins Wasser zu springen, weiß der Geier. Ähm
äh so aber äh äh nichts dergleichen und wenn er auch größeren Schaden hätte verursachen
wollen, sage ich mal, wäre er nicht auf der rechten Außenspur gefahren, sondern wäre dann wahrscheinlich eher äh wenigstens in die auf die linke Spur
dann hätte hätte halt auch die andere äh Fahrbahn noch mehr Schaden äh und der Zug vielleicht auch noch. Also
sind jetzt alles keine Beweise, dass er nichts davon äh wusste, aber für mich deutet das doch doch alles sehr darauf hin.
Und auch äh ja die Art der der Bombe hm das ist so das das nächste Ding.
Mhm.
Deutet darauf hin ähm ja äh dass da einen Geheimdienst drin verwickelt war, weil.
Sie ist zwar also nicht also,
ich würde schon sagen, dass das auch in der Möglichkeit oder Kapazität von Amateuren liegt, so eine Bombe zu bauen.
Aber äh diese war schon,
relativ so fest dekated und wahrscheinlich auch ganz gut getarnt und äh sagen, ich würde sagen, Semibal, ein professionell
improvisierter äh äh Sprengsatz, so würde ich äh das Ganze ein.
Einstufen, also nix, nix irgendwie Standardmilitär äh Sprengstoffe, sondern schon irgendwie eine spezieller Mix.
Und äh für mich sieht das auch sehr danach
aus ähm dass es sich um Flüssigkeiten gehandelt hat, äh die da
explodiert sind, also äh quasi ähm zusätzlich so was wie eine wie eine AirBomb äh zum Einsatz gekommen.
Wobei äh ja auch zusätzlich noch äh vielleicht Aluminium oder andere äh Metalle
äh äh drin gewesen sein könnten oder schon noch ein bisschen auch äh Oxidator, also,
muss wahrscheinlich eine ziemlich spezielle Mischung gewesen sein.
Die Russen meldeten auch, dass in den Papieren die Ladung als äh irgendwie
Film oder Film äh was ich mal so interpretiert habe, Film in dem Sinne jetzt äh keine Filmrollen oder so, keine Videos, sondern,
Folien und wenn man sich anguckt, wie Folien transportiert werden, dann werden die halt so.
Großen Rollen transportiert, so kann man nicht mal angucken und was ich mir gut vorstellen könnte, wenn das, wenn das stimmt, dass äh diese Sprengsätze äh möglicherweise als große Rollen.
Mit Aluminiumfolie.
Getarnt waren. Ja, das würde so ein bisschen das Gewicht erklären so und dann im Prinzip auf Palette und noch schön isoliert, dass man's nicht genau sehen kann und.
Waren dann aber in Wirklichkeit eigentlich große mit ja entsprechender Flüssigkeit und entsprechendem äh äh Zünd
Zünd High Explosions gefüllt, vielleicht einfach
vorstellen einfach so als Zylinder, der dann in der Mitte durchgeht, so dass das dann im Röntgen aussieht einfach wie so eine Spindel mit einem mit einem Innenkern äh und und so, also äh das.
Wer zumindest ähm so wie ich mir das plausibel vorstellen könnte und,
gezündet wurde sie relativ sicher nicht durch.
Mhm äh durch einen durch einen Zeitzünder hm denkbar wären zwar auch ähm.
Dann durch.
GPS durch im Prinzip einen einen Geofans, der dort gesetzt äh wurde, dass wenn hm wenn der einen bestimmten Punkt erreicht, dass die gezündet wird,
wäre.
Eine Möglichkeit meine Vermutung wäre, dass wenn das ein Geheimdienst professionell gemacht hat, äh dass sie mehrere Redundante Zünder und auch mehrere redundante Bomben.
Hatten. Ich
das Gefühl aus dem Explosionsbild könnten das drei Stück gewesen äh sein, von denen eine zuerst gezündet ist und die zweiten dann nicht mehr so richtig
äh ja äh zünden konnten oder äh dann schon deformiert waren und dann so mehr mehr verbrannt als explodiert äh sind. Also man sieht da, dass das halt
das teilweise sehr in der Explosion, dass das.
Teilweise unregelmäßig passiert und dass dann noch äh
im Nachgang teilweise mehrere Sekunden später noch irgendwie Treibstoff oder Fehlmengen aufflammen irgendwo
die ja noch nicht noch nicht entzündet äh war. So und.
Ja wahrscheinlich, also was sein könnte ist, dass halt äh entweder jemanden mit einem starken Fernrohr von,
Land aus das Ganze gezündet hat,
oder hm ja in einem anderen Fahrzeug, was lang gefahren ist, was aber schwer zu koordinieren ist wegen der wegen der Kontrolle. Also konnte halt niemand genau wissen, wann dieser LKW über die Brücke geht.
Es gab dann aber noch ein paar Fragen, okay war das jetzt wirklich die ideale Stelle, weil okay einerseits der Zug, der der übrigens mehr seit mehreren Stunden,
dort gestanden haben soll, was wohl auch ein bisschen merkwürdig ist, weil normalerweise stehen die Züge da nicht so lange auf der Brücke rum.
Äh so das hat dann bei einigen auch wieder gesagt, hm war's dann vielleicht doch vollsfleck und haben die den Zug da extra geparkt und stehen lassen für diese.
Aktion ähm ähm ja.
Und dann äh eben auch die Überlegung, dass eigentlich ja der Schaden viel größer gewesen wäre wahrscheinlich, wenn sie das Ganze
auf dieser äh Spannbogenbrücke zur Explosion gebracht hätten. Ob das zu sagen entweder die Ukrainer da
ja das zu früh gesprengt haben oder das zu früh in die Luft gegangen ist oder
absichtlich halt die Spannbogenbrücke verschont
wurde äh auch wegen möglich Getreideexportabkommen, dass man das nicht gefährden äh äh wollte
Aber äh ja, also es bleiben, ich sage mal, eine ganze Menge merkwürdigkeiten
an der Stelle.
Ich glaube, die Getreideexporte spielen jetzt keine Rolle, weil meines Wissens wird über das gar kein Getreide exportiert.
Nähen nur das sozusagen Russland, deswegen das Abkommen aufkündigen könnte.
Ach so, ja okay.
So, das war dann, weil so nach dem Motto ja äh.
Das könnten Sie natürlich trotzdem machen, aber dann ich meine, Sie haben sich ja zu diesem Abkommen ohnehin äh nur bereit erklärt, war einfach der Druck aus dem Süden zu groß wurde und sie eben den globalen Süden nicht,
als Allianz verlieren wollen. Also ich glaube jetzt gut kann man tausendfach drüber äh spekulieren. Bleiben wir vielleicht erstmal noch mal so bei diesem eigentlichen Schaden.
Also das Ganze ist im Prinzip.
Macht es so den Eindruck, als ob es sich um so eine thermobarische Bombe handelt, die halt äh so funktioniert, dass ein initialer Sprengsatz diese ganze Flüssigkeit, was auch immer das ist, Benzin.
Wie auch immer.
Alkohol. Mhm.
Alkohol, irgendwas äh muss man sich ja vielleicht auch noch um Gestank Gedanken machen, je nachdem, wie gut das da einge
ist. Auf jeden Fall wird diese Flüssigkeit dann eben durch diesen Initialen Sprengsatz erstmal vaporisiert und dann mit einer zweiten Zündung überhaupt erst
äh zu zu dem gefährlichen Springkörper gemacht. Äh der ist dann letzten Endes ist.
Und es spricht auch sehr dafür, weil dieser Zug hat ja dann Feuer gefangen. Jetzt ist natürlich so ein Zug, der erstmal.
Nicht so fuffzig, 80 Meter entfernt ist, sehr viel höher stand, weil die Brücke, die Autobahnbrücke, ist relativ niedrig über dem Wasser. Die Eisenbahnbrücke ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon,
hoch, weil die ja nicht so eine extreme Steigung machen kann, wie die,
Autos sehen dann äh fahren. Ähm und äh da ist ja eigentlich nicht so viel, was da brennen kann. Klar, das sind zwar Tankwagen, aber die sind selber, diese Tanks haben ja gehalten, die sind ja nicht.
Gegangen. Das ist ja nicht der Zug explodiert, sondern es ist einfach nur dieses ganze Gemisch von dieser eigentlichen Explosion
auf alles niedergeregnet, eben auch auf diesen Zug und dort hat es dann eben lange weiter gebrannt, weil einfach,
schließt einfach diesem diese Menge an Zeug, da so
groß war, so dass dann eben auch äh diese Züge relativ lange gebrannt haben. Ähm das war ja dann auf allen Fotos zu sehen, mit viel Rauch und äh Feuer äh et cetera.
Hat's eben nicht gereicht, diese Tankzüge selber dann nochmal zum explodieren zu bringen. Die sind ja auch sehr stabil gebaut.
Ja und ich glaube, das war auch Diesel oder Heizöl oder so, was die geladen haben könnten. Äh deswegen hat das auch so lange gebrannt. Benzin wäre wahrscheinlich eher dann hochgegangen.
Ja okay, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Auf jeden Fall hat es eben gereich.
Äh zumindest diese.
Dieses eine Gleis, auf dem dieser Zugstand weitgehend zu zerstören an der Stelle. Gab jetzt noch mal.
Äh Videoaufnahmen davon, wo man sieht, dass eben einfach alles sehr heiß geworden ist, diese Schienen sind komplett deformiert, also man sieht richtig, wie dieser,
Tankwagen dann mit mit der ganzen Hitze dieses ganze Schienenwerk auseinandergepresst hat, sprich.
Eingesunken ist, in die Schienen so richtig die Schi.
Genau. Also um das wieder äh herzustellen, muss man einfach den ganzen Schienenkörper austauschen. Die Brücke selber dürfte aber okay sein, weil die ist ja auch komplett aus Stahl.
Das heißt, da gibt's jetzt keinen Beton, der irgendwie hätte brüchig werden können und äh der Stahl führt natürlich diese ganze Hitze dann auch gut ab. Klar, die Schienen sind im Eimer
aber äh da ist ja nochmal ein Schotterbett dadrunter.
Und äh diese dicken Stahlträger, die sie da verbaut haben, die sind jetzt nicht so ohne Weiteres äh.
Die Bredouille zu bringen, macht zumindest den Eindruck, sodass man davon ausgehen kann, dass die äh Russen auch in der Lage sein sollten, innerhalb eines gewissen Zeitraums
den sie jetzt brauchen, um erstmal diesen diese zerstörten Tankwagen dort zu wegzukranen
und dann eben dieses Gleisbett neu aufzusetzen, dass ihr vielleicht so in einer Woche oder so auch wieder einen Betrieb aufnehmen können, wobei die zweite Seite die zweite Schiene erschien mir von den Bildern, die ich gesehen habe, weitgehend
unbeeinträchtigt, wobei es natürlich auch sein kann, dass dort auch Schienen noch mal ausgetauscht werden müssen.
Ja auch mein Eindruck und die Brücke ist wohl.
Für so etwas grundsätzlich ausgelegt, weil man quasi damit geplant hat, dass eventuell dort
Zug auf der Brücke in Brand geraten könnte und die ist eben so ausgelegt, dass die wohl einen brennenden Zug äh einfach aushält, aber äh ja
Man wird sehen ähm wie lang das das das dauert, weil das war schon schon heftig so, was da und.
Ich bin mir da nicht hundertprozentig sicher.
Äh ja wie groß die äh oder also die die Schäden könnten größer sein als es äh von von außen so ohne Weiteres sichtbar.
Hätten aber auch geringer ausfallen können.
Also es war schon jetzt auch ein bisschen Glück mit diesem Zug. Äh sicherlich auch,
diesen Zug hätte es dort auf den Schienen ein Feuer gegeben.
Weiß nicht, inwiefern jetzt die Tatsache, dass der Zug da stand, dass noch in irgendeiner Form begünstigt hat, weil der ja selber so nicht gebrannt hat.
Nee, doch, doch der war halt dort auch der Zugzug war schon ein großer Faktor äh äh also der der Treibstoff, den der geladen hat, der da
ja verbrannt ist. Ähm also was wohl ein bisschen angeblich soll er soll er von der Krim gekommen sein, der Zug, was auch ein bisschen seltsam.
Mein Verständnis ist, dass der dass der Treibstoff in den Zügen selber nicht gebrannt hat.
Doch, doch, doch, doch.
Sehr lange her, der hat sehr lang äh die sind die sind äh durch Splitter äh die sind halt durch durch Splitter sind sind dann wohl die Tanks äh auch.
Worden. Ach so, oh.
Und dann ist Sprit ausgetreten und die sind zwar nicht explodiert, das ist richtig, aber
sagen und es ist auch nicht es sind auch nicht alle ausgebrannt. Entweder waren nicht alle voll oder äh sagen, die sind so gut geschützt, dass quasi selbst wenn einer brennt, sich das dann nicht auf den Nachbarwagen automatisch
sagen Fortpflanzigerweise.
Oder sie äh ich glaube, sie haben auch dann irgendwie es geschafft äh dann noch einen Teil abzukuppeln und ein paar wegzu äh äh fahren von von dem Brandherd.
Ja, also mit Hubschraubern gekommen, haben versucht, das äh von Hubschraubern auszulöschen.
Nach ein paar Stunden war auf jeden Fall der Brand dann im Griff, aber das hat dann eben schon äh ausgereicht, um dort eben zumindest jetzt die unmittelbare Schienenstruktur zu.
Zerstören, die da jetzt.
Ist, ne? Ja, gut so, also das ist das, was äh dort passiert ist und es macht natürlich so den Eindruck, dass jetzt hier die Ukraine wirklich eine.
Einfach eine eine echte Räuberpistole abgezogen hat und einfach gut drüber nachgedacht hat, okay, wie können wir diese Brücke in irgendeiner Form beeinträchtigen.
Ohne dass wir die Möglichkeit haben, sie mit Raketen zu treffen, ohne dass wir die Möglichkeit haben, damit Booten hinzukommen, weil dafür ist die einfach zu gut abgesichert, auch mit ihren normalen Raketen hätten sie durchaus befürchten müssen
Sie von der dort natürlich existierenden Luftabwehr abgefangen werden, aber auch so ein Lastwagen war Russland irgendwie nicht,
vorbereitet, ganz offensichtlich, zumindest nicht in ausreichendem Maße und durch diesen,
diesem Spediteur, der was weiß ich, da vielleicht auch schon 30.000 Mal rübergefahren ist über diese Brücke und den.
Die da einfach kannten, ja ähm haben sie's einfach geschafft, da äh.
Einzuschmuggeln, die sozusagen ja man vielleicht.
Nicht ja, die nicht äh hätte durchgelassen werden dürfen. Inwiefern das mit dem Zug jetzt ein Zufall ist.
Also ich kann mir das irgendwie kaum vorstellen, dass man sowas planen kann. Das ist.
Na ja, wie gesagt, der der stand da halt wohl sechs Stunden oder so lang auf auf der Brücke.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, die haben äh hatten ja das sozusagen nicht in der Hand, wann dieser Fahrer wirklich losfährt und außerdem.
Hatten sie ja nicht in der Hand zu regeln, wann dieser Zug dort steht.
Und dass da dass der da überhaupt steht. Da hätte jetzt irgendwas stehen können. Da hätten auch irgendwelche Panzer äh stehen können. Ich würde mal vermuten, dass das eher nochmal so Glück im Spiel war.
Oder äh einfach ähm ja äh wie gesagt, da war irgendein Spotter, der das beobachtet hat und der halt den Knopf äh äh gedrückt hat und dann gedacht hat, ja okay, nehmen wir den Zug oder es war.
Zufall und es ist zu früh explodiert und man wollte es eigentlich auf den Bogen explodieren lassen, aber äh ja.
Das werden wir vielleicht nie rauskriegen oder vielleicht dann erst in ein paar Jahren, bis man nicht. Auf jeden Fall waren die Auswirkungen
jetzt auf mehreren Ebenen erheblich. Da ist natürlich dann erstmal so der mentale Schock, ne, weil das ist natürlich so das Prestige-Projekt von äh Putin gewesen, was er selber eröffnet hat. Das ist äh ein ja
auf jeden Fall ein Schlag gegen ihre Logistikkette, ganz klar, selbst wenn sie nur temporär ist, denn.
Nicht temporär.
Na ja gut, also ich meine was die Zugverkehr betrifft unter Umständen schon.
Na ja, nee, es gibt noch so ein paar Faktoren natürlich jetzt, die die dauerhaft wirken, ganz unabhängig von der Instandsetzung der Brücke, weil.
Sie jetzt natürlich erstmal äh die Kontrollen intensivieren müssen, um.
Zu verhindern, äh dass so etwas nochmal passiert. Ähm.
Was natürlich zusätzlich jetzt einfach die Kapazität.
Reduziert für LKW, weil intensivere Kontrollen und eventuell gibt's auch noch einen anderen Twist äh weil äh kam gestern auf ähm.
Weil eventuell müssten sie jetzt alle,
Wagen zukünftig Röntgen, die da drüber wollen, aber,
wollen Sie denn tun, jetzt dagegen, dass jemand so einen Wagen reinschickt,
und die Röntgenstation in die Luft sprengt. Ja, das ist sozusagen jetzt die neue Bedrohung.
Sie können jetzt eigentlich keinen Wagen röntgen, weil die Gefahr besteht, dass dann jemand die Röntgenstation in die Luft springt und sie keine Wagen mehr könnten.
Ja, so heißt möglicherweise äh quasi ist ich sage mal ist die Gesamtgefahr.
Sich so etwas wiederholt und sie das nicht vermeiden können, dass sich so etwas wiederholt. Ähm
auch einen Grund dafür, dass Sie vielleicht erstmal bis auf Weiteres keine LKW Transporte oder keine LKW
über die Brücke fahren lassen, überhaupt, selbst wenn sie das das aushalten könnte und wenn, dann eben nur in deutlich reduzierter Zahl, weil sie dann von Hand im Vorfeld kontrollieren müssen und und und so. Das heißt,
Das ist eine Wirkung, selbst wenn sie die Brücke instand setzen, sagen ist halt jetzt eine neue Bedrohungssituation entstanden, die
quasi dauerhaft dazu führt, dass der Verkehr langsamer äh läuft auf der auf der Brücke.
Das das ist so sozusagen auch eine interessante Nebenwirkung.
Genau und es hat ja auch schon erwähnt, dass die Brücke ist halt so auch die Lifeline für die Krim
Und es ging dann relativ schnell. Dann gab's äh lange Staus vor den Tankstellen auf der Krim. Es wurden auch offiziell schon äh bestimmte Lebensmittelrationiert in den Supermärkten, wenn man eben sich sofort drauf einstellen musste, okay, jetzt.
Ist hier die permanente Versorgung durch Lastwagen. Die ist jetzt auf jeden Fall schon mal gestört. Und wir wissen ja, wie das so läuft mit den Lieferketten, haben wir ja hier auch.
Bei Corona auch schön gesehen, dass dann schnell mal das Toilettenpapier alle und dann wollen das alle irgendwie haben und dann äh führt das zu noch mehr Verzerrung, weil die Leute dann eben Hamsterkäufe machen. Außerdem,
lange lange Schlangen in die andere Richtung, weil natürlich jetzt viele auch Schiss bekommen und sich denken so oh oh,
jetzt schon die Brücke angegriffen wird, dann verlasse ich mal lieber die Krim, hier geht's bald los, nachdem's ja schon ein paar Explosionen an Militärstandorten äh et cetera gegeben hat.
Ja, ja. Also zu den Hamsterkäufen, also was ich gehört hatte, war, dass sie
nicht nur nicht nur für bestimmte äh äh Nahrungsmittel, sondern dass sie erstmal pauschal gesagt haben, jener Einkäufer darf maximal zweieinhalb oder drei Kilo.
An Waren mitnehmen, egal was, ja.
Wenn du einkaufen gehst, nur nur eine halbe, nur eine halbe,
äh im Prinzip, egal was.
Ja. Also ich denke, man kann schon davon ausgehen, dass das halt jetzt eine.
Attacke der Ukraine war und dass sie sie hier einfach extrem klug vorgegangen sind.
Also vieles sehr vieles spricht dafür. Also auch die also zum einen die Reaktion und unverhohlene Freude äh darüber, die äh ukrainische Offizielle an den Tag.
Gelegt.
Haben, so auch äh Selensky konnte sich halt so ein bisschen den Grinsen nicht nicht verkneifen, als er dann darüber berichtet äh hat. Ähm.
Ja äh,
also äh plus für eine Operation hm ja ist es ein bisschen zu krass und
So meine Überlegung war na okay, wenn Putin dahinter gesteckt hätte oder irgendwelche Russen, die provozieren äh wollen, dann hätten die das äh
auch eher tagsüber gemacht, äh wenn da viele Zivilisten äh auf der Brücke,
sind äh also das wäre dann noch ein bisschen blutiger gewesen. Wir hätten dann nicht sechs Uhr früh gewählt äh für den für den Anschlag.
Wahrscheinlich auch eine koordinierte äh äh Attacke auf Social Media äh gegeben, so wie wir sie nach der Gaspipeline gesehen haben. Davon war auch nix zu sehen. Also das hat sich schon auf dem linken Fuß erwischt und das war jetzt sicherlich nicht auf ihrer Bingo.
Mhm, ja. Es gab auch, ja, gab auch die These, dass das äh ja ähm.
Okay, also in dem in dem Zusammenhang ist jetzt, äh wenn man jetzt davon ausgeht, dass die Ukraine das jetzt war, dass die dahinter steckt. So habe ich mich gefragt, okay, wussten die USA eigentlich vorher davon?
Passieren würde und haben die USA in irgendeiner Weise mitgeholfen, hätte die Ukraine.
Die Hilfe der USA gebraucht und äh also da da
definitiv nein. Dass die Ukrainer völlig alleine hinkriegen können. Die Frage ist, ob sie das gemacht hätten ohne die Amerikaner vorher zu fragen und ich glaube
äh dass da auch meine Einschätzung ist nein
Das hätten sie also das Risiko wären sie glaube ich nicht eingegangen äh bei so einer bei so einer gravierenden Sache.
Und ähm ja mit anderen Worten, die wahrscheinlichste Variante ist, dass.
Äh die Ukraine, die USA gefragt haben, ist das okay, wenn wir das machen und die USA sagt, ja ist okay. So.
Also warum sollst du sie überhaupt fragen.
Mein, das ist halt schon ein ein weiterer Eskalationsschritt
äh einfach und das ganze Vorgehen, Aufklärung äh äh weiß ich nicht und einfach die Gefahr sozusagen die USA zu verärgern äh äh da.
Gut, aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie spezifisch genau diese Aktion so vorangekündigt haben, sondern bestenfalls einen was ist, wenn wir die Kehrbrücke angreifen, auf welchem Weg auch immer ohne eure Waffen.
Seid ihr da clean mit. So, das, denke ich mal, dürfte das Maximum gewesen sein.
Mhm und ähm mir überlegt habe, okay, was könnte jetzt die Motivation für die USA gewesen sein, war sie ihr okay zu diesem,
weiteren Eskalationsschritt äh zu geben und da könnte man jetzt mutmaßen auch, dass das quasi.
Dass die Pipeline
Geschichte dort wiederum eine Rolle spielte die ja auch noch irgendwie weitgehend ungeklärt ist äh wer oder was da jetzt dahintersteckt. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, dass die Russen äh das waren oder die Amerikaner glauben, dass die Russen das waren. Äh
quasi ihr okay eben auch die Signalisierung äh sein könnte von also.
Ihr habt auch Infrastruktur, die äh angegriffen werden kann, ja? Also äh haltet euch mal zurück.
Irgendwie Pipelines, so das könnte halt quasi,
auch so eine Motivation gewesen sein, deswegen die Amerikaner okay waren äh damit. Aber pure Spekulation.
Aber äh ja, erscheint mir zumindest nicht völlig unplausibel. Wie gesagt, dass die Amerikaner informiert waren.
Und ihr okay gegeben haben äh zu der Aktion, wenn's die Ukrainer war.
Ja, ich denke, mehr lässt sich jetzt zu dieser Brücke erst mal nicht äh sagen, außer dass man jetzt natürlich drüber rätseln kann, welche Auswirkungen es haben wird.
Doch so ein paar also was man vielleicht nochmal betonen muss, dort ist ja schon kurz angesprochen, welche Bedeutung diese diese Brücke einfach hat, ja okay, dann schieß los.
Wenn man sich nämlich jetzt die Situation nochmal anschaut ähm wie das so mit den Versorgungslinien aussieht. Der ganze Angriff der,
Russen basiert auf Eisenbahnstrecken.
Deren primäres Logistiksystem und ihr sekundäres Logistiksystem Trucks bricht ziemlich auseinander. Wenn man sich anschaut, was mittlerweile für Fahrzeuge von Russland eingesetzt werden, um Dinge zu transportieren, merkt man, dass sie einfach
echtes Problem haben genug Fahrzeuge zu bekommen.
Sie.
Verlieren auch relativ viele Tankfahrzeuge et cetera, also diese ganze äh Logistik, genug Material an die Front zu bekommen, insbesondere Treibstoff, die hängt eben schon sehr von Eisenbahnverbindungen ab
Jetzt ist es so, dass es natürlich ursprünglich vor zehn Jahren gab's mal natürlich ein komplett geschlossenes Eisenbahnnetz. Aber durch den Vorstoß.
2014 im Dombas wurde die Eisenbahnverbindung aus Donutsk in Richtung Saborysia.
Also das, was jetzt sozusagen die Landverbindung ist, die sich Russland da zusammen erobert hat, die wurde unterbrochen.
Und zwar nicht, indem da mal irgendwo ein bisschen Gleis rausgenommen wurde, sondern so dies so nachhaltig zerstört worden, dass es dort einfach keine Verbindung gibt. Das heißt, es gibt keine Möglichkeit für Russland aus Rostov, was so ihr südlicher.
Anknüpfungspunkt wäre ähm in die Ukraine von dort Züge in den Süden der Ukraine fahren zu lassen. Das läuft alles über diese Brücke. Das heißt, diese Brücke versorgt die ganze Krim.
Diese Brücke versorgt. Den ganzen Südraum bis hin nach Mariopol.
Mit Zügen und natürlich auch die Verbindung nach äh Resorten über den Fluss. Wenn jetzt diese Brücke Probleme hat und das hat sie jetzt.
Kommt das zum Erliegen. Vielleicht erstmal zum vorübergehenden Erliegen, aber es ist definitiv eine Einschränkung. Du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, dass jetzt das Problem haben
LKWs können nicht mehr über die normale Brücke fahren. Das heißt, die müssen dann teilweise auch mit Zügen fahren. Das bedeutet wiederum, dass die Kapazität sinkt. Ist noch nicht ganz klar, wann sie die,
Das zweite Gleis dort hinbekommen. Ich habe nochmal nachgeschaut. Es gibt auf dieser ganzen Brücke keine Weichen, auch nicht auf dieser Insel.
Bisschen ungewöhnlich ist. Die können Sie natürlich jetzt noch einbauen.
Aber im Prinzip, solange sie auch nur ein Gleis verwenden können, haben sie das Problem, dass sie eben jetzt so ein komplett blockierten Streckenabschnitt von ungefähr 30 Kilometern haben, wo dann immer nur ein Zug drauffahren kann,
quasi oder vielleicht auch mehrere hintereinander, aber eben nur in eine Richtung. Und äh ja, das schränkt natürlich diese Versorgung,
ein, wenn sie nebenbei auch noch die Krim am Leben erhalten wollen und das ähm wird auf jeden Fall dazu führen, dass weniger geliefert werden kann, als sie das derzeit ähm könnten.
Inwiefern jetzt diese Brücke voll ausgelastet war, war kann ich nicht beantworten ähm aber da ist auf jeden Fall einiges los gewesen.
Und psychologisch natürlich.
Ist diese Brücke auch äh sehr eng mit Putin verbunden, er hat dir persönlich eröffnet am Steuer irgendwie eines Kammerstrucks, der da
ja
triumphierend dann über die Brücke äh so auf die Krim,
und hier ist eigentlich auch ein Symbol, ne mal für seine territoriale
Erweiterung äh Russlands, um die um die Krim und auch ein Symbol, ich sage mal, für ja die Dominanz und die Anbindung äh der.
Der Krim äh und das ist halt schon äh eine extreme.
Ja ein extremer Affront
gegen gegen Putin persönlich auch und gegen den Status der der Krim und äh ja
und die russische Volksseele kocht äh halt darüber entsprechend, weil eben äh ja
auch die die größte äh also längste äh Brücke in Europa, sagen die Russen
stimmt nicht ganz, je nachdem ob man die Länge der Eisenbahnbrücke oder der Straßenbahnbrücke nimmt, ist dann halt die irgendwie Wasko Dagama-Brücke in Portugal etwas länger. Die liegt genau zwischen der Länge der Eisenbahn und der
der Straßenbrücke, die halt leicht unter die Eisenbahnbrücke ist, glaube ich, zwei Kilometer länger oder so als die Straßenbrücke. Und äh ja
Also sozusagen auch der russische Nationalstolz, die Leute meinten, das wäre so ein bisschen wie
Wenn äh ja die Golden Gate Bridge äh in San Francisco irgendwie jetzt plötzlich gesprengt oder bombardiert wurde, so vergleichbar vielleicht?
Im Bewusstsein der Russen. Ich hätte natürlich einen etwas anderen Status, aber so in der Richtung oder
vielleicht wie der erste Anschlag auf das World Trade Center, nicht nine eleven, sondern.
Die die als da die Parkgarage gesprengt wurde, so der erste Versuch.
So diese Dimension, vielleicht äh hat das jetzt in der russischen Wahrnehmung.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall hat sich die Ukraine mit diesem Ding ähm wieder hm etwas.
Zeit erkauft.
Kann man sagen, hm in der Russland nicht so sehr,
die Fronten versorgen kann und das natürlich genau in dem Bereich, den sie jetzt vor allem aufm KiKa haben.
Und das äh ist auf jeden Fall ein.
Ja ein Sieg für.
Für die Ukraine.
Ja, aber einen Tag später ging's dann äh schon wieder los und Russland schlug äh zurück beziehungsweise äh.
Wurde es zwar offiziell als Antwort auf diesen Anschlag dargestellt, aber ich glaube, man kann davon ausgehen.
Dass das äh schon länger von langer Hand geplant war, nämlich ein Raketenhagel, der.
Über dem gesamten Staatsgebiet der Ukraine niedergegangen ist, vor allem eben auf große Städte und dort primär auf die äh Energieinfrastruktur und natürlich auch auf zivile Infrastruktur.
In Kiev und auch in vielen anderen Städten. Gestern waren's
etwas in der Größenordnung von 85Raketen und Drohnenangriffen in der Summe
von denen gut die Hälfte von der Luftabwehr der Ukraine auch schon vorher runtergeholt werden konnte, was schon mal an sich eine große Leistung ist, aber da blieb halt noch viel Schaden übrig.
Und ähm ist noch nicht ganz abzusehen, wie lange Russland das so durchhalten möchte und kann.
Wie gesagt, während wir jetzt diese Sendung aufnehmen, gibt's schon wieder Berichte von weiteren Angriffen.
Also heute sollen äh nochmal bisher 20Raketen abgefeuert äh worden sein, wird man sehen, dass halt deutlich
weniger also diese Raketenschläge sind halt.
Unglaublich teuer äh auch. Also äh je nachdem wie man die Preise ansetzt bei diesen Rüstungsgütern, das ist immer nicht nicht ganz so einfach. Äh.
Dürfte der Preis für die gestrige äh äh Barage äh so für für Russland
ähm in die hunderte Millionen äh gehen, was diese Waffen gekostet haben
äh wobei wahrscheinlich gar nicht der Preis so das Problem ist, sondern dass sie im Moment wahrscheinlich auch nicht in der Lage sind
die Dinger nachzuproduzieren, weil
einen Großteil der der Teile dafür und nicht nur die Elektronik, sondern auch äh teilweise das Metall äh für die für die Hüllen oder für die für die
Ende der Raketen kamen halt aus Deutschland.
Also Deutschland hat halt einen größeren Anteil an wenn man auch ja.
Mitteilen für für russische Waffen äh.
Und so, also ich zähle diese Raketen.
Und großen Mesalt und ja, wie gesagt, die Dinger sind halt sind halt ziemlich teuer und meine Schätzung war
dass wir daran jetzt auch ablesen können, wir werden können wie
wie lange Russland es jetzt aufrechterhalten kann, wie's um die russischen Reserven dort äh bestellt ist und,
Äh ich ich würde schätzen, dass wenn die Russen so etwas 5 bis zehn Mal machen würden, dann ist.
Alle. Ja, da ist wirklich nix mehr da so, ja.
Äh also das ist sozusagen irgendwo die Gesamtkapazität der Russen, wenn sie sich komplett nackt machen äh würden, was sie glaube ich aber ja gut, weiß man nie, wenn sie jetzt der Meinung sind, sie müssten jetzt irgendwie erstmal alles geben und dann halt
zu sehen, dass sie dann irgendwie ohne Präzisionswaffen auskommen, aber das kann ich mir halt auch nicht vorstellen, dass sie sich jetzt dann wirklich.
Entblößen, aber wenn Sie jetzt wie gesagt, das wäre so meine äh Schätzung und.
Offensichtlich hat es ja heute schon äh äh deutlich.
Abgenommen, sodass äh ja für die Russen das das eben nicht nur kostspielig ist.
Sondern äh der Angriff erfolgt ja von vier verschiedenen Seiten gleichzeitig. Das heißt, das musste dann auch noch koordiniert werden.
Ähm einige der Crew Mist halts sind wohl auch über Moldawien hinweg geflogen.
Bevor sie dann im.
Von Schiffen im Schwarzen Meer abgefeuert worden.
Und äh ja, da ging den bestimmt.
Auch der Arsch auf Grundeis, kann ich mir vorstellen, wenn dann plötzlich über deinen Territorium
so ja ein ganzer Schwarm an Raketen oder
unterwegs ist, gut per Raketengan ist relativ schnell äh sagen, wo die hingehen oder es sich nicht treffen, aber,
weiß das halt nicht äh so, die können halt auf jedes Ziel programmiert.
Sein und aber das zu äh koordinieren, also es ist jetzt auch nicht so.
Einfach wie ja schießt mal, sondern da mussten halt
lange wenn man Ziellisten auch vorbereitet werden und übermittelt werden und dann,
Waffen selbst halt auf die ganzen Ziele erstmal äh programmieren und beladen und scharf machen und das das das Ganze und
ja die Schiffe in die richtige Position bringen ähm und
dass das alles machst du nicht irgendwie von von sag mal einer, einer Nacht auf die andere damals, als die Amerikaner nach nine eleven.
Ja die ersten Crewsmiths, Strikes auf Afghanistan durchgeführt haben. Das hat 14 Tage gedauert, bis sie äh.
Das vorbereitet äh hatten.
Ja gut, aber die mussten ja auch erstmal hinfahren.
Ja äh wobei die waren die waren schon in der Nähe und so nah musst du da nicht ran mit den Dingern. Die haben eine ziemlich große Reichweite äh und so und.
Ähm also
das ist so die Größenordnung und die die die Planung äh braucht. Das heißt, je nachdem wie viel die jetzt
plant haben oder wie viel die da auf der auf der Liste haben. Äh du willst natürlich die andere Sache, du willst natürlich auch gucken wo,
wo hat man getroffen und wo müssen wir irgendwie jetzt vielleicht noch mal nochmal nachsetzen oder nochmal äh wiederholen das Ganze, das das könnte halt auch sein, aber meine.
Erwartung, wie gesagt, ist, dass die das Russland diese Intensität nicht.
Lange äh wird durchhalten können, bestenfalls Tage, wenn überhaupt.
Ja ich denke auch, das wird keine langanhaltende äh Sache sein, ohne dass wir jetzt natürlich genau wissen zu können.
Da ist natürlich jetzt der Durchhaltewillen der Ukraine gefragt und zwar sowohl jetzt natürlich der mentale an dem ich mir ehrlich gesagt relativ wenig Sorgen mache.
Das wird ja eher noch dazu führen, dass dass ihr Widerstand
äh weiter anwächst. Äh andererseits sieht man natürlich auch, was das Ziel ist. Das Ziel ist die Energieinfrastruktur, möchte also quasi jetzt hier
Heiz- und Strominfrastruktur der Ukraine ausschalten,
wird sich zeigen, wie groß die Schäden sind, wie reparabel die Schäden sind, aber das ist natürlich jetzt im Hinblick auf den Winter. Äh
auch nochmal wieder so ein weiteres ähm ein weiterer Gang in seinem Menü der Grausamkeit.
Ja.
Aber in ja, also Erfahrungen so aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg haben gezeigt, dass diese die ganzen Bombardierungen der Alliierten, die ja irgendwie mit,
tausend Flugzeugen zum Teil auf einmal angegriffen haben und sich dann 10.000 Tonnen Bomben irgendwo abgekippt,
haben, dass selbst die oft nur für mehrtägige,
Produktionsunterbrechungen gesagt haben und äh verglichen mit dem, was
Russland da jetzt abgefeuert, hat ist das ja mit der also verglichen mit der Größe des des Landes ähm.
Äh ja äh,
kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jetzt lange dauern wird, die die Schäden äh wieder wieder zu beheben. Das heißt, Russland müsste es quasi jetzt über längere Zeit aufrecht.
Erhalten und ähm ansonsten ja sagt Infrastruktur,
lässt sich normalerweise relativ schnell äh reparieren und es gibt viel, viel mehr Infrastruktur äh,
als man denkt, so gut Problem sind natürlich Kraftwerke so, das kann dann kann dann länger dauern, aber ähm also es ist.
So, es ist eigentlich äh so oder so schwierig einen einen Land jetzt äh aus der Luft.
Irgendwie nennenswert ähm ja seine seine Kampfkraft oder so zu schwächen, das ist das ist das ist so oder so schwierig und ähm.
Mit, ich sage mal fünfzig Explosionen oder so ähm kannst du zwar ein bisschen Schaden machen, aber im.
Verglichen mit der Größe der Ukraines, das ist das nicht. Es ist halt das das Bedauerlichste äh wie gesagt sind dann die Verluste an an Menschen
leben und äh militärisch weiß ich nicht.
Also ich halte das halt für einen für einen Fehler äh ins insbesondere.
Jede dieser Raketen, die da jetzt in irgendwelchen Parks,
in irgendwie im Stadtzentrum oder auf Spielplätzen
eingeschlagen ist, fehlt ja um militärische Ziele anzugreifen, ja und er hat dann
an der Stelle Russland, keine Ahnung. Äh jetzt pro.
Pro zerstörter Infrastruktur wahrscheinlich also prolohnendem Ziel irgendwie 1 bis 20 Millionen investiert und ich glaube, der Schaden an vieler dieser Ziele äh.
Ist erreicht, diese Größenordnung äh äh nicht und so was macht halt nur Sinn, wenn man vorhat,
das Land dann anzugreifen, also quasi als als Vorbereitung für eine für eine folgende.
Invasion äh nochmal, um dann um dann vorrücken zu können. Aber das muss dann auch schnell passieren. Ja, das musst du dann ausnutzen, weil ich sage mal in spätestens ein, zwei Wochen
ist dieser Effekt dieser Schläge weitgehend verpufft. So würde ich das, würde ich das einschätzen und dann war's halt.
Fast verschwendete Liebesmüh.
Außerdem gibt das halt unschöne Bilder wieder in der Welt und zum Beispiel aus Indien kam jetzt deutlich.
Daran und auch aus anderen Ländern, die gesagt haben so nee, das das finden wir jetzt nicht gut, was
Macht, so wie ihr da jetzt einfach äh die.
Ukraine beschießt aus Russland waren das natürlich alles jetzt präzisionsangriffe so die äh äh ja alle nur militärische Ziele ausgeschaltet haben und.
Alles perfekt und super gelaufen.
Ich meine, diese Angriffe könnten natürlich politisch auch jetzt noch mal insofern zurückfeuern, als dass natürlich die Ukraine jetzt ähm sagen kann, gucke mal, hier äh wir brauchen jetzt auch long rangewaffen.
Weil wir eben vor allem von Long Range bedroht werden.
Das bedroht unsere Zivilisten, das bedroht unsere zivile Infrastruktur, das ähm bedroht das Überleben der Ukraine im Winter. Ähm.
Jetzt äh hat Russland sozusagen von sich aus einen Eskalationsschritt gemacht.
Auf dem man dann wieder mit einem weiteren Eskalationsschritt antworten kann.
Keine Ahnung wie die Diskussion jetzt in Bezug auf äh diese Attac MS äh äh Raketentechnik, die Ukraine ja gerne einsetzen würde, jetzt bereits hat.
Aber auf jeden Fall und das sieht man ja jetzt schon äh werden wahrscheinlich,
Lieferung für Anti-Reinsysteme, also Luft ähm.
Na Luftschutz.
Luftabwehr.
Luftabwehrraketen ähm da werden sie jetzt sehr.
Flugabwehr, Flugabwehr heißt es glaube ich.
Flugabwehrrake
äh es kommt durcheinander mit den ganzen Military Turms. Auf jeden Fall äh Deutschland war er dann auch schnell dabei zu betonen, dass ja die Iris T-Systeme, die wir hier vor ein paar Sendungen schon mal besprochen haben, wie
gut deep aufm Papier zumindest äh sind. Die dass die ja hier sehr gut hätten gut helfen äh können. Dass die
dass das erste von vier Systemen wohl in den nächsten Tagen geliefert werden soll. Das war, glaube ich, die Aussage von.
Ja, Harry Up, kann ich nur sagen, ne?
Wenn die jetzt schon mal dagewesen äh wären, keine Ahnung wie viel die dann jetzt geholfen hätten und so weiter, aber es äh sicherlich jetzt mit den Systemen nicht schlechter als äh ohne.
Auch die äh USA wird sicherlich dann auch nochmal mehr dort in den Gerättopf äh greifen.
Na ja und dann eben, wie gesagt, wäre es natürlich jetzt interessant zu sehen, ob sich an der Diskussion der Long-Range-Raketen was ändert, denn es ist ja klar, in dem Moment, wo.
Die Ukraine über diese Attack MS Raketen verfügt. Was ihr erstes Ziel wäre.
Es wäre die Krimbrücke. Weil die wäre damit erreichbar.
Und wenn sie, sagen wir mal zehn, 20 davon auf den Schienenweg ballern, dann wird der Schaden nehmen.
So
wenn kein dauerhaften permanenten Schaden zumindest einen, der sich nicht in zwei Tagen reparieren lässt. Insbesondere wenn Sie da einen konstanten Flow von diesen Raketen haben und im Prinzip jeglichen Reparaturversuch, kurz nachdem er stattgefunden hat, gleich wieder rückgängig machen können.
Man wird ja, man wird sehen. Ich bin bin gespannt äh so, also auch äh wie gesagt, ob ob's jetzt noch äh weitere Schläge ähm.
Gegen die Krimbrücke äh geben wird. Also eigentlich wäre das jetzt nur logisch, weil irgendwie mehr.
Mehr Reaktionen so in Russland kann das jetzt auch nicht.
Nicht auslösen. Es ist jetzt akzeptiert, dass es ein legitimes Ziel ist. Westen hat keiner protestiert.
Dagegen, sondern es wurde auch mitgejubelt, sage ich mal. Also insofern ja hm.
Können denselben Trick nochmal machen.
Na ja die äh die Gefahr besteht natürlich ähm ich meine diesmal könnte man vielleicht auch was in den Zug packen ähm so.
Aber äh könnte schwieriger werden. Müssen wir jetzt aber es gibt wahrscheinlich noch noch weitere
Ideen oder Methoden, an die so vielleicht noch noch keiner gedacht hat. Wobei die Russen ja im Grunde genommen schon an alles gedacht haben. Es hat halt nur nicht nur nicht funktioniert und,
Denkmal auch, dass dann jetzt die nächste wahrscheinlichste Variante wäre, äh ja, einen einen Angriff mit einer großen Menge an.
Äh ja Kurzstreckenraketen.
Sind noch nicht mal Mittelstreckenraketen im aber mit ja taktischen äh äh Raketen so.
Zwei, 300 Kilometer Reichweite, zweihundert, 300 Kilo Sprengköpfe oder so, die machen dann schon.
Ziemlich verwüstung.
Gut, kommen wir zum nächsten äh Thema. Das ist ähm.
Jetzt nicht mehr ganz so umfangreich, aber wir müssen natürlich mal schauen, wie sieht's denn jetzt mit den konkreten, militärischen Offensiven aus, die die Ukraine ja vor längerer Zeit schon gestartet hat und die zuletzt soviel Fahrt aufgenommen haben. Wir hatten ja hier in der letzten Sendung
über beide äh Fronten, wo es richtig ähm Aktivität gibt, berichtet. Einerseits in äh Luhansk und eben jetzt,
äh auch in äh fahren wir jetzt vielleicht mal durch die Nähe der Krim in ähm damit an.
Ähm ja
Was ist passiert? Hm ein bisschen was, aber nicht so viel. Es gab ja den Angriff ähm also noch mal zur Erinnerung, die Situation ist ja die,
in äh ein Teil der russischen Truppen und zwar ein nicht unerheblicher Teil der russischen Truppen ungefähr,
was ich schätze und gehen so auf 20000 Soldaten und natürlich entsprechend viel äh Gerät. Die stehen ja auf der rechten oder Westseite des Nitro und besetzen eben dort
die Stadt Resshon im Oblass-Resshorn und äh das war eine relativ lange Front und ähm.
Die Ukraine äh hat, dann im Osten dieser Region.
Im Nordosten dieser Region eine ja gestaffelte Offensive gestartet und relativ schnell die Russen zurückgedrängt.
Bis zu einer neuen Frontlinie, die jetzt so in der letzten Woche von den Russen weitgehend gehalten werden konnte
Es gab also keinen weiteren Vorstoß. Es gab noch mal ein oder zwei Dörfer, die den Besitzer gewechselt haben, aber äh ansonsten macht es derzeit dort den Eindruck, als,
sich gerade alles ein wenig konsolidiert einerseits und andererseits der Widerstand der Russen dann an einem bestimmten Punkt so groß war, dass jetzt die Ukraine
ihre Offensive so jetzt erstmal so nicht fortsetzen konnte oder wollte.
Gehört ja auch immer was dazu bei solchen Vorstößen nicht zu schnell voranzuschreiten, damit man das gewonnene Gebiet auch.
Sichern kann, sich selber absichern kann gegen andere Gegenangriffe
und ähm ja, trotz alledem gibt's Fortschritte, es werden da nach wie vor viele russische Flugzeuge und Hubschrauber abgeschossen
generell ist so die Berichtslage äh weiterhin so,
eben sowohl die Moral der russischen Soldaten nicht besonders äh gut ist und vor allem auch ihre Versorgung und ja, dadurch dass jetzt eben die Krimbrücke auch noch attackiert wurde und natürlich weiterhin mit den Heimatsystemen im Hinterland.
Systemen im Hinterland, ähm Kommando Controlposten, Munitionslager, äh Treibstofflager, et cetera angegriffen werden, verbessert sich die Situation nicht. Also da kann man natürlich jetzt nicht wirklich reinschauen, aber es gibt schon Berichte von
einer gewissen Treibstoffarmut, weil einfach nicht genug Diesel nachgeführt werden kann und selbst wenn jetzt diese Truppen sich nicht bewegen,
ja? Brauchen die ja am laufenden Meter Diesel. Warum? Weil diese Panzer müssen jeden Tag laufen.
Den ganzen Tag laufen, aber die müssen laufen, damit die Batterien aufgeladen werden.
Keine andere Möglichkeit haben, diese Batterien aufzuladen und diese Batterien, das halt wie beim Auto ja, wenn die halt irgendwie platt sind, dann springt er halt gar nichts mehr an. Und äh von daher ist auch jeder Tag, wo.
Anführungsstrichen nichts passiert, ist ein Tag, wo Sprit verbraucht wird und.
Nicht wenig, die den einen, die fressen ja eine ganze Menge und dementsprechend werden diese ganzen Vorräte reduziert.
Das führt dann streckenweise dazu, dass Panzer dann quasi nur noch als Artillerie eingesetzt werden können, weil die halt einfach gar nicht mehr fahren können,
Sie haben genug Sprit um die sozusagen am Laufen zu halten.
Aber nur noch in irgendwelchen Stellungen eingraben und äh benutzen die im Prinzip wie Artilleriegeschütze.
Also man muss sehen, äh wie das hier läuft, wenn
wenn sich so ein bisschen die Muster der letzten Monate äh fortsetzen, dann würde ich damit rechnen, dass es halt einfach,
Konsolidierung an der Front gibt, dass die Ukraine weiterhin schaut
wo ist der Widerstand gegebenenfalls am geringsten und dann entsprechend umdisponiert. Die Russen stehen hier wirklich mitm Rücken zur Wand. Die Wand ist dann halt in diesem Fall der Fluss.
Und äh von von dahinter kommt eben nicht sehr viel Unterstützung.
Und von daher sehe ich durchaus Möglichkeiten, dass diese Offensive wieder aufgenommen wird und dass die Ukraine halt andere Stellen findet, wo sie äh angreifen können.
Es gibt noch einen
Ort, über den's am Anfang viel Gerüchte gab, ob er denn schon gefallen sei, das ist wohl noch nicht der Fall. Das ist äh die Stadt nie Horiphka. Ähm vielleicht noch mal so zur ganzen.
Geographie, also dieses ganze umkämpfte Gebiet dort teilt sich im Prinzip in zwei Teile in ein Ost- und einen Westteil. Im Ostteil.
Ist die Stadt äh Entschuldigung, im Westteil ist die Stadt angesiedelt und dieser Ost und dieser Westteil wird ihm von diesem Fluss
getrennt, der da so von Norden nach Süden durchmehren darf. Und ganz am Norden an der Frontlinie liegt eben diese Stadt. Die von den Russen noch gehalten werden kann, wie es aussieht
würde die Ukraine dort einen Vorstoß erfolgreich durchführen können und diese Stadt wieder zurückerobern können.
Was ich durchaus für möglich halte, dann hätten sie einen weiteren neuralgischen Punkt ausgeschaltet, weil das nämlich im Prinzip auch die Stadt
ist, wo derzeit die einzige Bahnlinie durchgeht. Ähm es gibt eigentlich zwei Bahnverbindungen zwischen äh,
dem Nord und dem Südteil dort äh des das eine ist halt die Bahnbrücke Bayrasson, die ist aber zerstört und das andere ist eben die Bahnbrücke bei Nova Kahofka. Die ist eigentlich auch,
äh derzeit zerstört. Also ich glaube, da fährt derzeit nix, ne? Also sehr schwierig überhaupt da was reinzubringen.
Ja ich ich glaube äh die beim Damm haben die das einfach zugeschüttet und ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass da das.
Züge wieder zum Laufen gebracht bekommen haben. Genau, aber trotzdem, die Bahnstrecke von Nova Kajowka führt dann nicht am Fluss entlang nach Hershon.
Sondern geht quasi schräg nach oben nach äh und von dort schrägt wieder runter. Da gibt's also keine Querverbindung, weil es gab ja die andere Bahnbrücke, deswegen war das nicht erforderlich. Ähm
kontrolliert man diese Stadt, kontrolliert man dann eben auch diese Bahnlinie.
Einerseits, andererseits ist es dann eben auch um die eigene Logistik voranzutreiben, wiederum ganz hilfreich, weil dann die Ukraine sich eben dort äh äh an diesem Ort äh mittelfristig dann auch besser
mit Eisenbahn selber versorgen könnte. Das muss man also alles
abwarten. Äh ansonsten passiert da erstmal gerade nicht sehr viel.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, also meine Erwartung äh äh dort ist, dass äh jetzt wieder eher so eine Phase ist, wo die Ukrainer versuchen äh.
Den Gegner weich zu kochen und äh ja.
Moment zuschlagen.
Ihn abzunutzen und eigentlich dann darauf zu warten, dass er anfängt, sich zurückzuziehen und dann wieder nachzusetzen, das könnte irgendwie.
Der Plan äh der.
Könnte der Plan sein, aber das Problem ist natürlich auch, diese ganze Region ist sehr straßenarm. Es gibt dort nicht sehr viele befestigte Straßen und.
Noch ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, wie das Wetter dort ist, aber wir nähern uns jetzt eben dieser Regensaison.
Da unten ist wohl noch gut im Moment da unten ist.
Da ist noch gut, aber das.
Sich halt irgendwann ändern. Das heißt, die Zeit läuft in gewisser Hinsicht ein wenig ab. Das betrifft natürlich dann beide, aber es wird sicherlich schwieriger sein, diese Strategie der Umfahrung und Einschließung von
russischen Stellung, wie sie die bisher äh primär durchgezogen haben, dann in demselben Maße fortzusetzen
keine Ahnung, vielleicht denken sie sich noch irgendwas anderes, pfiffiges aus, aber ich denke, da ist dann auf jeden Fall so ein Punkt erreicht und könnte mir auch vorstellen, dass sie noch bevor es dort zu matschig wird, zumindest
ein oder zwei weitere strategische äh Punkte erreicht haben, also die Stadthon, weiß ich nicht, das ähm.
Kann natürlich dann mit diesen anderen Punkten zusammenhängen, wenn sie zum Beispiel bei diesem Damm bei Nova Kakowra wenn sie dort erfolgreich wären.
Im äh im Westen, das wäre natürlich schon mal ein Blow, weil damit werden dann im Prinzip alle Versorgungslinien komplett gekappt. Ähm.
Aber das ist noch nicht so weit.
Insgesamt haben wir auch noch bemerken, ja die,
die Frontlinie hat sich verkürzt auf jeden Fall äh da unten, was natürlich für beide Seiten so ein bisschen bedeutet, dass die die Truppendichte auf beiden Seiten
auch äh zugenommen hat äh so äh wobei das auch wiederum unter anderem der Ukraine jetzt ermöglicht
dort vielleicht Truppen erstmal abzuziehen oder auszutauschen oder an andere Stelle äh zu verlagern, wenn sie dort äh nicht
jetzt erstmal weiter pushen wollen.
Rotation.
Zur Verteidigung, zur Verteidigung reichen einfach weniger Truppen, während du zum Angriff äh wie gesagt brauchst du halt so doppelt bis dreimal so viele ungefähr, damit äh ja
das nicht zu blutig wird und dass damit du überhaupt Chancen hast äh da
da vorzudringen. Normalerweise so und das war dann auch glaube ich ja also man musste jedenfalls äh äh deutlich,
ja Truppen konzentrieren und.
Soll auch so, dass die Truppen in äh dass die Ukraine in anderen Gegenden sagen, auch Konzentration von Truppen vorhält, die stärker sind, als man sie nur zur Verteidigung
bräuchte, äh sodass äh sie quasi in der Lage sind, wenn sie an anderer Stelle jetzt eine Offensive machen wollen, müssen sie nicht.
Nicht so stark verstärken, sondern da sind zwar nicht jetzt im Moment nicht genug versammelt für eine Offensive, aber sie müssten dann, was weiß ich, nur noch.
Ein Drittel dazu packen und haben dann genug für eine Offensive. Das ist sozusagen auch eine Art und Weise, wie die Ukraine aufgestellt.
Hm.
Was man noch dazu sagen muss, es gibt Berichte, dass jetzt bei dem letzten Rückzug der Russen das nicht ganz so chaotisch gelaufen ist wie zuletzt in Lüman. Also es sind nicht in demselben Maße ähm.
Gerät äh Gerät zurückgelassen worden. Also man hat nicht mehr so viel Munition erbeuten können und äh Geräte, also das finden natürlich trotzdem statt. Gibt immer wieder etwas, was in die Hände der Ukraine fällt. Von daher ähm hat sich das nicht.
Geändert, aber es macht so ein bisschen den Eindruck, als ob sich die Russen dort schon seit Längerem auf einen Rückzug auch eingestellt haben. Und den.
Quasi logistisch schon mal vorbereitet haben.
Und dort kämpfen halt teilweise äh ja oder überwiegend sogar die besten Truppen, äh die äh Russland aufzubieten hat.
Also diese derzeit noch aufzubieten haben.
Ja ja, also da da ist.
Ja, da ist äh überwiegend äh ja professionelles Militär, auch Fallschirmjäger und motorisierte Bataillone und so ist sozusagen man fast sagen, Großteil des Kerns
äh der russischen Streitkräfte äh äh befindet sich da wohl.
Die aber jetzt auch also sollen dort tatsächlich auch schon erste Wehrpflichtige angekommen sein, auch auch auch dort. Äh was man da äh daran weiß, dass auch die ersten schon übergelaufen sind.
Ja genau. Also übergelaufen oder eben auch schon äh getötet worden sind.
Blicken wir nochmal auf die andere ähm Frontlinie, wo die Ukraine stark aktiv ist, also äh die ehemalige Offensive, die ich jetzt im Luhansk-Offensive nennen würde, weil man steht jetzt
unmittelbar an den Toren der ähm ja der des Oblas Luhansk genau.
Es sind wohl nochmal es sind also nur irgendwas in der Größenordnung von 150 Quadratkilometern des äh Oblas Rakiev, die jetzt noch nicht befreit worden sind.
Aber an manchen Stellen hat man eben diese Grenze zu Luhansk auch schon überschritten,
Ja und das äh ist in einem ähnlichen Zustand. Also auch dort ich würde nicht sagen, schweigen die Waffen, aber gibt es jetzt gerade keine größeren Fortschritte. Es gab kleinere Fortschritte. Insgesamt.
Sieht so aus, dass man jetzt diese Verteidigungslinie dort zwischen diesen wichtigen Orten und Krimina.
Äh in Angriff genommen hat. Dort haben sich die Russen entsprechend verschanzt.
Da äh bietet das Gelände auch, sagen wir mal, noch geringe Möglichkeiten, das zu tun. Und das ist ja auch ein Bereich, der jetzt eben sehr lange gehalten wurde und nach diesem Schock des Vorstoßes in
äh haben sich die Russen ja dann äh dort quasi neu äh gesammelt und soweit verstärkt, wie es ihnen möglich war.
Denke, jetzt ist es hier auch wieder so ein Abtasten
Letztlich ist die Frontlinie schon so auf 15 Kilometer aufs Wattauet vorgestoßen und sollte es eben dort noch gelingen, diese Stadt auch noch einzunehmen, dann wird's da langsam richtig eng.
Ja, also die die Gegend oben, wenn man sich das dann auch im Satelliten anguckt.
Äh Satellitenbild anguckt, wo,
das Ganze jetzt stattfindet, da sieht man, dass.
Die Kämpfe jetzt in oder die die Front jetzt in eine Gegend gelangt ist, wo auch Manöverkrieg etwas erschwert wird dadurch, dass ähm es dort größere Waldgebiete gibt.
Und die Siedlungen äh sich quasi genau dann zwischen den den Wäldern befinden und ähm es dann nur
eine Möglichkeit.
Quasi zwischen zwei Wäldern durch mit Panzern oder Fahrzeugen durchzufahren und ähm das macht es halt ein bisschen
schwieriger dort diese ja so einen schnellen mechanisierten Vormarsch
durchzuführen, weil eben die entsprechenden Former,
Wege, die man benutzen könnte, entweder vermient oder eben entsprechend unter ja, Artillerie äh äh Feuer gesetzt äh werden können und
das macht es ein bisschen mühsamer jetzt auch äh.
Und lässt erstmal keine äh schnellen Fortschritte erwarten.
Ja, das muss man abwarten. Da ähm.
Wird sicherlich in den nächsten paar Wochen wieder was äh passieren, aber derzeit äh passiert da nicht viel. Ja, bringt uns zu unserem vorletzten äh Punkt oder vorvorletzten Punkt.
Wollte mal so ein bisschen draufschauen, was ich denn so an Waffentechnik dort äh Neues eingefunden hat und was das unter Umständen für Auswirkungen haben kann.
Du hast äh unter anderem neues Material der Bundeswehr ausgemacht.
Ja und zwar die sogenannte Smart Suchzündermunition der Bundeswehr.
Ähm auch wieder so ein bisschen erinnert mich so ein bisschen auch an an Iris T. Ähm.
So vom Prinzip her und das Ding ist halt obwohl ich glaube jetzt über 20 Jahre alt schon ähm wirklich wieder krasse Hightech. Ähm und.
Und die Amerikaner haben sowas in der Art nicht, die haben das zwar auch getestet, äh sich dann aber für was anderes entschieden, also die Amerikaner haben halt bei diesen Excalibur äh.
Und anderen intelligenter Präzisions Artillerie geschossen, sage ich mal, die sind entweder.
Äh GPS äh ähm,
gesteuert, sage ich mal. Das heißt, die steuern dann eine bestimmte Koordinate an.
Auf die du sie vorher programmierst und ja manövrieren äh dann im Flug dahin oder.
Die zweite Art ist, du beleuchtest das Ziel mit entsprechenden
Infrarot äh
markern, also Sequenzen, Blinksequenzen im Prinzip schnelle Blinksequenzen, äh die eine eindeutige Nummer haben und auf die dann auch ein Geschoss äh äh sich
äh sich einstellen äh kann. So.
Ersteres natürlich mit den GPS-Koordinaten eignet sich nur bedingt für bewegte Ziele natürlich, weil klar, du hast halt feste Koordinaten.
Und
müsstest du es wenn dann genau timen, dass da ein Beobachter ist, der dann sagt okay in sechs Sekunden oder so ist dann der Panzer an der Stelle, also jetzt feuern, was halt sehr, sehr schwierig ist oder brauchst du eben eine anderen Forward
Observer, der oder eine Drohne, die halt des des Ziel markiert. Diese.
Smart-Suchzündermunition dagegen ähm die.
Feuerst du einfach ab über in die Gegend des des Ziels,
öffnet sich die unterwegs, äh bremst ab mit einem Fallschirm und äh wirft dann.
Zwei
ja Wirkkörper oder wie auch immer man das nennen kann, aus, die dann auch jeweils äh noch mal einen einen Fallschirm ausklappen, einen rotierenden.
Und dann äh in der Drehbewegung mit drei verschiedenen Sensoren, einem Infrarot äh Sensor.
Einem aktiven hohen Millimeterwellenradar und einem passiven äh Millimeterwellenradiometer.
Das Zielgebiet absuchen und das ist, es gibt da zwei Varianten, äh das ist dann ungefähr dann Durchmesser zwischen.
Von 80 bis 110 Metern, also anderthalb bis dreieinhalb Hektar ungefähr, äh die.
Ähm jedes dieser Geschosse absucht und es hat intern dann eine.
Algorithmus, Algorithmen, die dann aus den Sensordaten errechnen.
Irgendwelche Militärfahrzeuge hm im Suchbereich sich finden und kann die wohl auch erkennen
und äh unter Bäumen und so, weil mit dem Radar, das kann da halt durchgucken und das kann auch die äh Temperatur.
Messen kann halt kalte von warmen Zielen unterscheiden und kann dann teilweise auch wahrscheinlich erkennen in welcher Farbe oder mit welcher Art von Lack äh und so die die lackiert sind. Genaue.
Spezifikationen sind geheim, aber es wird eben auch gemunkelt, dass es die Möglichkeit gibt, äh sagen auch nochmal spezielle Arten von von Technik,
äh zu fokussieren und zu sagen, wir möchten gerne vor allem ja Luftabwehr, Hardware oder nur Panzer oder so.
Aber standardmäßig muss man da erstmal nix machen. Das hat halt ganz gute die Vollsettings.
Ist halt einfach nur 155 Millimetergranate, die zum Beispiel von der Panzerhaubitze 200 verschossen werden kann und
da ein schönes Video.
Wo die Leute äh also wie die Ukrainer in Deutschland trainiert worden sind, sowohl an der Panzerhaubitze 200 als auch im Einsatz dieser Smart Suchzünder-Munition.
Und was diese Wirkkörper dann machen ist äh auf dem Weg nach.
Wenn sie dann ein Ziel identifiziert und verifiziert haben, feuern dann aus.
Ungefähr zehn, zwanzig Metern äh würde ich würde ich sagen, vielleicht 30 Metern Entfernung explodiert das Dingen und formt.
Einen äh Penetrationskörper, also der wird.
So sagen im im Prinzip einen flüssigen Metallstrahl der dann aus 20, 30 Metern Entfernung äh auf das äh Ziel abgefeuert
wird und äh ja, das dann,
durchlöchert so und da sie sind halt auch hervorragend geeignet für bewegte Ziele.
So äh und äh für natürlich äh sind gedacht für da kommt halt ein Militärkonvoi
Und wir feuern der der ist in Bewegung, fährt auf uns zu und wir feuern halt einfach jetzt über den Konvoi in der Bewegung äh äh diese Geschosse ab und die suchen sich dann, ich sage mal, die teuersten Ziele.
So ungefähr.
Krass.
Und äh äh und äh das geht auch so schnell, dass selbst in voller Fahrt äh einen Panzer sozusagen nimmt Zeitpunkt aus, wo.
Dann der der.
Äh das Ziel gefunden hat und auslöst, sich ungefähr nur 50 Zentimeter weit bewegt. Das heißt, deswegen muss das Ding noch nicht mal groß jetzt interpulieren oder so, sondern das geht halt irgendwie zack beim,
und äh und.
Drauf gestoßen äh bin ich bin ich halt, weil eben Bilder aufgetaucht
sind von äh ja entsprechenden Angriffen, wo dann Leute gesagt haben, oh das sieht aber äh ganz nach eben smart äh Suchzündermunitionen aus und
Ähm und es gibt da.
Sondern so eine bisschen charakteristisch aussehende Wirkung, nämlich dass halt das Ding eben bisschen oberhalb quasi zündet,
und äh die,
Explosion, ja sie sieht halt ein bisschen anders aus und auch die Wirkung oft ist ist anders ähm da fliegt nicht,
wie bei einer normalen Hiexplosiv-Granate, die einen Panzer
einschlägt, fliegt äh fliegen halt gleich irgendwie Teile weg, sondern das ist mehr wird halt von von oben so ein bisschen durchlöchert und äh je nachdem
wo dann die die die Löcher sind, dauert's dann unter Umständen bisschen äh und
dann fängt das Ding an zu brennen oder explodiert und als ich das dann sagen mir an.
Geguckt habe, habe ich mir dann halt mehr Videos nochmal durchgeguckt und äh ist natürlich teilweise oft aus der Ferne und es ist halt keine.
Zeitlupe, sondern das geht eben sehr, sehr schnell, deswegen war's immer mit Vorsicht genießen, aber
Äh ich hatte das Gefühl, dass es eine ganze Reihe von Treffern äh gab, vor allem Panzer in der Fahrt, wo man dann spektakulär gesehen hat, so oh wow, wie machen die Ukrainer das, dass sie hier jetzt
voll irgendwie Bullseye äh äh auffahrende Panzer und
eine Erklärung äh könnte mit dafür sein, dass dort sehr erfolgreich dieses Smart-Such zu einer Munition zum Einsatz kommt, wo du, wie gesagt, dein Geschoss nur irgendwo
ja ich sage mal in einem Radius von 50 Metern oder so äh um das um das Ziel.
Bringen musst, fünfzig, 60 Metern und dann egal, was was die machen so.
Und es geht eben auch äh sehr schnell, weil's eben eine Arte ist, im Gegensatz zu jetzt anderen Raketenwaffen oder so.
Mhm ist je nach je nach Entfernung äh dauert das halt fünf, sechs Sekunden oder so vom vom Abschuss äh bis das Ding dann dann dort dort ein.
Schlägt tatsächlich und äh gibt's auch nicht viel, was man tun kann dagegen.
Okay, schauen wir mal, was das äh noch so bewirkt.
Generell zum Thema Munitionslieferungen.
Mich auch noch auf ein paar interessante Einschätzungen gestoßen ähm und zwar hm.
Ist es wohl so, dass seit Beginn auch jetzt des des Kriegs damit begonnen wurde nicht nur aus allen möglichen jetzt NATO-Ländern, die.
Munitionskeller Munitionsbunker zu lehren und an die Ukraine äh zu liefern, sondern.
Quasi weltweit, weil man weltweit hat ja fast jedes Land irgendwo.
Irgendwelche Stockpilets, auch Länder, die mit diesen Konflikten,
die mit dem Konflikt jetzt gar nicht so direkt was zu tun haben und es gibt auch viele Länder äh die man jetzt nicht so direkt
zum westlichen Bündnis zählen
würde die eben auch munitionsfabriken haben und Artilleriegeschosse herstellen oder auch die NATO oder NATO-Länder beliefern, also Prinzip in Südamerika, in
Afrika, in Mexiko, in Asien ja bisschen in China.
Und ähm zum einen wurden halt wohl weltweit Bestände von ähm,
Warschauer Paktwaffen.
Aufgekauft, die halt irgendwelche Regime noch rumliegen hatten, also die Waffenhändler hatten wohl Hochkonjunktur und ähm.
Dass eine und dann ist es äh wohl auch so, dass eine Reihe von,
NATO-Ländern, also Polen, aber auch andere Länder, also ich glaube Portugal wurde auch genannt, hat möglicherweise auch Tschechien und Slowakei und so.
Ähm die kaufen halt einfach äh Munition für sich ein.
Ländern, die jetzt direkt.
Die Ukraine nicht beliefern würden, aber jetzt keine Probleme damit haben irgendwie ein Nato-Land äh zu beliefern oder Land X zu beliefern und,
dann eben ja selber einkaufen und dann ja verschwindet die aber äh was weiß ich aus dem Stockpile der polnischen Armee ganz schnell die die neu eingekaufte,
Munition. Und äh ja plus äh das wohl jetzt grade.
Zum einen die USA, die äh Produktionslinien für verschiedene Munitionstypen.
Nicht nur hochgefahren hat, sondern auch noch mal erhebliches Geld in die Hand genommen hat, um weitere Produktionslinien aufzubauen plus,
ist halt große gibt, wo äh sagen wir mal also wenn du ab dreißigtausend
Granaten im Jahr
liefern kannst, dann kannst du dich irgendwie an der Ausschreibung beteiligen der US-Regierung äh für ja entsprechend. Munitionslieferung im Moment. Und dann
gibt es wohl auch noch größere Produktionskapazitäten im ehemaligen Ostblockländern.
Bulgarien wurde da genannt äh unter anderem Rumänien, Tschechien, Slowakei wahrscheinlich auch und.
Die hauen wohl äh grade auch äh äh richtig viel noch Munition äh raus, um
die ja Warschauer Pakt Hardware der Ukrainer und die, die sie für den Russen erobert haben,
weiter mit mit Munition äh zu versorgen ähm sodass wahrscheinlich ja also Einschätzung von Profis,
hat der Westen, also das steckt da so ein bisschen hinter der Frage so
gibt's im Westen eigentlich genug Munition, um die Ukraine zu versorgen mit
für die Alten und für die neuen Waffensysteme und die Antwort darauf ist.
Man muss ein bisschen zusammenkratzen und äh ein bisschen mehr rausgeben als man normalerweise würde, aber der Ukraine wird wohl nicht die Munition.
Ausgehen. Das ist die die Einschätzung, weil quasi Russland nicht nur,
die NATO, sondern mehr oder weniger gegen die ganze Welt kämpft und wie gesagt, sogar China wahrscheinlich. Äh Rüstungs,
Güter an die Ukraine liefert, aber nicht direkt.
Sondern äh da kaufen einfach Drittländer, kaufen einfach ein und dann geht das auch an die Ukraine. Also fand in Gedanken, weil wir immer überlegt haben, okay äh
sagen die Russen, wie umgehen die denn jetzt die äh Wirtschafts äh Sanktionen und für den Westen ist es natürlich noch viel einfacher, äh weil er erstens gar nicht offiziell sanktioniert ist und zweitens äh einfach,
Geld da ist und der Westen quasi in der ganzen Welt auch Rüstungsgüter für die Ukraine,
einkaufen und die dahin weiter fangen kann mit wesentlich weniger Aufschlägen und äh wesentlich weniger Hazle als die als die Russen, so das fand ich so ein interessanten Aspekt.
Äh an dem an dem Thema. Und um da jetzt nochmal dran dann anzuschließen.
Äh die die Russen haben dort ist ja jetzt das Narrativ, sie kämpfen ja in Wirklichkeit gegen die NATO.
Das sind ja gar nicht die Ukrainer, die in
dort entgegenstehen und er mir gefragt, okay wie viel Wahrheit ist denn jetzt steckt denn in dieser Propagandaaussage gegen wie viel NATO sage ich mal
kämpfen sie und ja versorgungstechnisch nicht nur gegen die NATO, sondern gegen die ganze Welt, aber.
Ansonsten
ja wird gestritten, ist es jetzt ein Stellvertreterkrieg, der dort stattfindet in der Ukraine oder nicht, aber äh das ist so ein bisschen auch Definitionsfrage, was ist ein Stellvertreterkrieg? War jetzt, ich sage mal
der Krieg Englands gegen Nazi Deutschland von 39bis
41 wo wo äh die USA nicht,
mitgekämpft haben, hat die USA jetzt einen Stellvertreterkrieg in Europa geführt eigentlich, weil sie England.
Munition versorgt haben so oder dann zumindest einen Monat lang auch noch die Russen äh.
So äh oder ja die Russen versorgt haben.
Äh die Russen jetzt einen Stellvertreterkrieg für die USA geführt im Zweiten Weltkrieg, weil sie versorgt wurden. So wenn man aber unabhängig von der Frage Stellvertreterkrieg oder nicht.
Ähm so kann sagen, okay, ein Land kann direkt
militärisch verwickelt sein in einem Konflikt in anderen Land, sprich eigene Truppen dort hinsenden, so wie man sich entnahmen, wo Amerikaner dann gekämpft haben dort, das heißt da bist du,
ja direkt involviert oder eben indirekt indem du beispielsweise Waffen lieferst und da kann man festhalten.
Dass die USA oder oder die NATO bisher ganz klar indirekt,
involviert ist äh während Russland direkt äh dort als äh Supermacht militärisch.
Einsatz ist, so dass es also schon mal der Unterschied zwischen jetzt,
wer kämpft eigentlich gegen gegen wen? Also es ist ja ganz klar eben keine direkte Konfrontation äh bisher mit der mit der NATO insofern ist die Aussage, wir kämpfen dagegen die NATO
na ja ähm und dann äh womit.
Man das vielleicht auch nochmal gut untermauern kann, wie viel NATO denn in der Ukraine jetzt.
Steckt, ähm die Schlacht um Kiew am Anfang
So da standen die Ukrainer mehr oder weniger alleine.
Kamen zwar dann so ein paar äh äh und ähm ja Stinger äh und so zum Einsatz, die uns dann alle angeguckt haben, aber der der eigentliche Kampf
womit die Russen wirklich zurückgeschlagen wurden, waren halt auch Artillerie und und Panzer, von denen wir aber nur nicht viel zu sehen
bekommen haben, aber Hostom äh da hat halt einfach klassische ukrainische Artillerie.
Einfach mal das gesamte den gesamten Flughafen unter Feuer genommen und die ganzen.
Truppen, die sich dort äh versammelt hatten äh einfach ja äh ziemlich hart getroffen.
Und ähm mit anderen Worten äh der.
Sag mal ja die ersten Kriegswochen äh da war die Hilfe der.
Der NATO oder so
eher von untergeordneter Bedeutung. So das haben die Ukrainer, würde ich sagen weitestgehend alleine geschafft. Klar, mit ein bisschen Unterstützung und die ist dann auch nach und nach
angelaufen und äh irgendwann ist das auch mehr geworden und äh aber äh die.
Sagen äh zum zum einen äh setzt die Ukraine ja bis bis heute noch
mehr ja äh Warschauer Pakt Kit ein, zum einen die ganzen Eroberungen von den von den Russen, die sie bekommen haben plus ihre alten Sachen plus das, was dann auch
von NATO Ländern geliefert äh wurde so von Tschechien und Polen und äh was die noch so
an an äh äh kompatiblem Equipment hatten und äh.
Und umgekehrt, wenn man jetzt auch hypothetisch aufmacht, die NATO.
Und die USA hätten sich da jetzt weitgehend rausgehalten an dem Konflikt, aus dem Konflikt wäre der sicherlich.
Nicht ganz so gut verlaufen für die Ukraine, aber sie hätte ja auch nicht völlig isoliert dagestanden. Es hätte trotzdem Länder gegeben, die
die Ukraine unterstützt hätten, unabhängig von USA und NATO und wo äh die Ukraine hätte einkaufen äh können oder
Geld gedienen worden wäre oder wie auch immer. Sodass ähm.
Ja äh unterm Strich, wenn man, wenn man das alles berücksichtigt, so dann ähm kämpft,
alt bisher äh äh Russland oder die russische Armee äh doch sehr klar gegen die ukrainische Armee äh mit allerdings zunehmender
Hilfe äh aus dem aus dem.
Ja von der NATO und stellt sich eben auch nach und nach um und dann ja werden halt auch Informationen geliefert.
Aber die äh ist dann die Vorstellung ja und äh dann äh sitzt keine Ahnung äh sitzen halt amerikanische und äh also NATO-Truppen überall mit,
an der Front und dirigieren dann die ukrainischen Truppen oder so, aber das halte ich für ja
Das das ist Quatsch. Ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn nicht ein einziger,
offizieller NATO-Soldat gerade auf ukrainischem äh ähm Gelände wäre, also wenn keiner äh äh äh da wäre im Moment, weil.
Ähm ja, es sind sicherlich Militärberater
da, die vielleicht eckwestliche Ex-Militärs sind für private Military Contractors im im Westen arbeiten und ich sage mal so unterstützen, aber
Der Unterschied ist zwischen einem regulären Militär und jetzt in so einem Contractor ist, dass der reguläre Militär einfach in die
Hierarchische Befehlsstruktur des Heimatlandes eingebunden
ist, ja und ganz klar äh bestimmte Loyalität hat, während du dann bei den äh Military Contractors, die sind wiederum äh oder jetzt auch Söldner oder Legionäre oder so sind halt ganz klar in die
ukrainische Militär und Befehlsstruktur
eingebunden. Das macht einen Riesenunterschied und meine Vorstellung, wie das halt funktioniert.
Äh mit sagen auch den Informationen und der Übergabe von dem Material und und allem, das passiert alles
auf westlicher Seite, die sitzen halt alle in Polen
und lassen die Ukrainer dann zu sich kommen, ja oder da sitzt dann halt ein ukrainischer Verbindungsoffizier in
Polen oder irgendwo anders im im Ausland und der übermittelt dann die Information nach Hause, aber nicht, dass da ein Amerikaner jetzt
vor Ort in der Ukraine sitzt. Klar, paar Militärattaschees und das das übliche Akkreditierte werden sie auch da haben, aber ich.
Glaube nicht, dass auch nur ein regulärer Soldat sich im Kampfeinsatz in der Ukraine befindet aus irgendeinem NATO-Land?
Ja, weil da hat dann auch Versicherungsimplikationen und was wenn dem dann was passiert und so und es ist auch gar nicht nötig. Also warum sollten die sich dann da äh.
Aufhalten, wo sie beschossen werden, wenn sie genauso gut
ja dasselbe gilt für Reparatur wird jetzt ein großes wurde jetzt doch ein großes Reparaturzentrum in Polen und eins in in Tschechien aufgebaut, das heißt wenn bei der Ukraine größere Reparaturen
sich an der Panzerhaubitze 2000 das Rohr ausgewechselt werden muss oder so, denn Karin, die das halt zurück über die
die Grenze, das wird dann da repariert und gewartet und wieder zurückgeschickt, so läuft das im im Prinzip dann. Ist keiner vor Ort.
Gut, ich habe da einen Punkt äh verstanden. Ich würde dir dahingehend ein wenig widersprechen wollen dass natürlich die Amerikaner von Anfang an,
im Bereich der Informationsbereitstellung äh eng verbunden sind.
Wo auch immer dann diese Informationsübergabe äh stattfindet
aber ähm viele strategische Entscheidungen basieren natürlich dann auch auf dieser Aufklärung
hier kommen natürlich dann auch NATO-Strukturen oder amerikanische Strukturen zumindest äh auf jeden Fall mit ins äh Spiel und das wird schon einen Einfluss äh gehabt haben, aber die generelle,
äh gegen wen kämpft denn Russland jetzt hier eigentlich, lässt sich schon ganz klar beantworten mit ja im Wesentlichen kämpft ja einfach gegen die Ukraine, die habt ihr auch übrigens auch angegriffen
und äh jetzt habt ihr äh den Salat.
Genau, gegen die Ukraine und den Rest der Welt so.
Ja der dann halt auch noch. Aber das sagen sie ja mittlerweile auch, dass sie gegen die ganze Welt kämpfen. Irgendwie so ist es halt, ne.
Gut äh vielleicht daran anschließend noch äh kurz, wir müssen ja mal auch zum Ende kommen. Es gab noch.
So ein bisschen Gerüchte äh Küche, das Darling an der Front, teilweise äh ausfällt
Häufiger als bisher zusammen noch gepaart mit solchen hm Gerüchten, dass irgendwie Starlink abgelehnt hätte, äh diesen Service auch auf der Krim bereitzustellen. Da habe ich keine Ahnung, ob das irgendwie stimmt oder nicht. Gibt allerdings ein paar
schöne äh Einblicke.
Auch nochmal so ein Twitter-Fred dazu. Welchen Herausforderungsdarling äh sozusagen sich gegenübersieht und
auf der Basis, wie es funktioniert, warum es so schwierig ist, weil natürlich die Russen versuchen Starling zu gejammen, wo es nur irgendwie geht und sie haben dann auch diverse Fahrzeuge, mit denen sie das äh
tun können und äh,
eine ziemliche Herausforderung. Das hat wohl dazu geführt, dass eben in bestimmten Frontbereichen teilweise äh die Truppen nicht weiter vorstoßen konnten, weil sie einfach irgendwie ihr Internet nicht mehr hatten. Und mittlerweile ist das halt so ein vernetztes Geschehen.
Das ohne Netz dann äh auch keine koordinierte Attacke mehr möglich ist. Also wir erleben jetzt hier im Prinzip auch schon eine komplette
digitalisierte äh und voll äh vernetze und in dem Sinne auch von vernetzter Infrastruktur abhängige Armee.
Zumindest was jetzt die aktuelle Strategie betrifft.
Dass sie da kein Vorbeck hätten. Ähm aber es macht mehr so den Eindruck, dass einfach Starlink jetzt hier mit äh tiefen Frontlinien zu kämpfen hat und da hat er.
Umso mehr man sozusagen in schlecht abgedecktes Gebiet und ein feindliches Gebiet vorgeht, aus Darlings so seine Probleme, weil du dann eben mit einem Jamming
so erfolgreicher sein kannst, umso äh schräger hier ein Satellit einen bestimmten Bereich abdecken muss, um überhaupt noch was anbieten zu können.
Übrigens die App gibt es wirklich. Also erinnerst dich, wir hatten ja mal über diese Artillerie App äh äh.
Ja? Mhm.
Genau
Und da habe ich mich dann auch immer gefragt, okay, wie welche Rolle spielten die tatsächlich jetzt und äh äh so, weil man hat's ja schon im Einsatz gesehen.
Aber der Ausbilder, der die Ukraine an der Panzerhaubitze 200 ausgebildet hat, hat die App auch erwähnt.
Und meinte, sie hätten halt die Ukrainer dann schon gleich so ausgebildet, wie sie denn auch,
zu Hause dann arbeiten würden. Das heißt, wir haben quasi die App
auch benutzt in der Ausbildung im im Training, so das ist quasi jetzt mehr oder weniger aus aus erster Hand von jemandem, der dieses Training äh äh durchgeführt hat und.
Zu dann noch ein Detail, weil das halt auch zu jetzt den Ausfällen.
Äh passt, an sich ist jetzt die Panzerhaube zu 2000 nicht so, dass man da jetzt mit Bluetooth und so einfach eine App lenken kann. Äh die hat aber ihre eigenen äh äh militärischen.
Äh Funk äh Netze mit den man
ja äh halt auf militärischem Funkfrequenzen Ziele digital äh übermitteln kann so. Also äh das das Feature hat das
auch äh bloß ich weiß nicht, wie wie eng die die App jetzt integriert haben, aber die haben die auf jeden Fall benutzt und.
Dieser Ausbilder meinte, es sei halt schon doch ein großer Vorteil, wenn man das jetzt über einen übers Internet,
machen könnte, Koordinaten austauschen, weil eben diese Funkschnittstellen gut zwar auf der einen Seite besser geschützt sind gegen
aber weil du keine Reichweitenbegrenzung hast, weil das du im Grunde genommen von überall
dann ja,
Tasks geben kannst und Koordinaten über übermitteln kannst und das sei doch ein erheblicher Vorteil, insofern.
Ist das ist das durchaus relevant dieses Ausfälle äh auch in dem Kontext.
Ja, dann noch eine kurze Anmerkung. Ich hatte das auch letzte Mal schon erwähnt, es gibt ja dieses Programm.
Ähm also wo quasi die Ukraine den russischen Soldaten explizit anbietet ähm wo sich ja schon so an die zweitausend.
Also letzte Woche hieß es,
da hätten sich schon so an die 20000 gemeldet und gesagt, so hier, ich möchte gerne. Sind ja jetzt ein paar Videos auch rausgekommen, wie so eine koordinierte Übergabe.
Stattfindet, also so quasi so ein ein eine Kapitulation. Da kommt dann so ein Panzer irgendwie so mit so einer weißen Unterhose übers Rohr äh rüber.
Irgendwie ausm Busch äh hervor, während die Ukrainer äh geschützt durch so.
Kleinen Graben äh sich das Geschehen anschauen, dann kommen die da halt hin, werden dann von einem vorstürmenden Ukrainern darauf
hingewiesen, sollten sich da jetzt auch mal bitteschön auf den Boden legen, was sie dann auch tun und dann wird das einfach so koordiniert äh durchgezogen und gibt ähm.
Auch ein paar andere Videos, wo äh solche Situationen gezeigt werden, wo die sich ergeben wo dann vor allem die Ukraine halt immer wieder sagen so, alles wird so sein, wie wir es abgesprochen haben, so. Das,
vier, fünf, sechs, sieben Mal äh wiederholt während dieses ganzen Sicherstellungsprozesses.
Das läuft also ganz erfolgreich. Äh die Hotline ist wohl auch überlastet von den ganzen Anrufen oder war sie zumindest zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Und man fragt sich natürlich, okay, was.
Wie kann das irgendwie klappen, ne? Also die haben da wirklich eine eine Telefonnummer, die können da
anrufen und sagen hallo, guten Tag, ich bin hier äh Russe, bin hier gerade eingezogen worden, ich will niemanden umbringen. Gibt's auch so Telefonmitschnitte, wo man das so sich anhören kann und äh Interviews, wie das abgelaufen ist.
Die Belohnungen sind auch nicht schlecht. Also abgesehen davon, dass sie halt überleben.
Gibt's, wenn sie dann auch noch Gerät mitbringen gibt's irgendwie 50.000 US-Dollar für einen Panzer, 25.000 für einen Schützenpanzer, 15.000 für so ein Mehrfachraketenwerfer, wo ich mich frage
Mehrwert, aber offensichtlich nicht,
1.000 für selbstfahrende äh Gans, also solche äh Haubitzen. Äh fünftausend immerhin noch für so diverse Mehrzweckgelände wagen, also so gepanzerte
Jeeps und so weiter, also ein äh Kram. Also wenn man quasi auch noch mit Gerät kommt, dann ähm hat man auch gleich noch was davon.
Und den Leuten wird halt auch angeboten, dass sie ähm.
Also entweder sie werden quasi einfach als Kriegsgefangene gemeldet und können dann auch wieder nach Russland äh zurück, wenn dann irgendwelche äh Austausch äh Programme äh vereinbart wurden
oder wenn sie überhaupt gar keine Lust mehr auf Russland haben, dann können sie irgendwie auch äh in der Ukraine bleiben auf die ein oder andere Art und Weise.
Gut, kommen wir zum äh Ende. Vielleicht enden wir noch mit einem kurzen äh Ausblick. Wie's jetzt weitergeht, teilweise klang das ja hier auch schon an.
Denke äh more of the same ist jetzt erstmal angesagt ähm wird natürlich vielleicht noch die ein oder andere Überraschung geben, gar keine Frage.
Aber ich denke mal,
grundsätzlich ist der Lauf der Dinge äh vorgezeichnet. Wir werden weitere Vorstöße der Ukraine sehen. Wir werden sehen, dass die Russen sich ähm.
Weiter in die Defensive einfressen, weil für eine Offensive ist derzeit einfach keinerlei Kapazitäten da.
Und äh viel wird natürlich auf so einer politischen äh Ebene ablaufen mit weiteren Drohungen, vielleicht mit weiteren Raketenangriffen, werden wir sehen.
Ja
Wir befinden uns natürlich nach wie vor in einer Eskalationsspirale oder in einer Eskalations.
Logik äh sage ich mal, weshalb natürlich,
auch äh immer wieder jetzt in letzter Zeit häufiger sagen
Die Frage atomare Eskalation führt uns das Ganze in den dritten Weltkrieg, was wir auch schon ja vor zwei Sendungen, wo wir
dass im Prinzip schon ja entdeckt hatten oder ich das Gefühl hatte, wir sind halt eigentlich genau
in äh so einer so einer Logik grade drin. Ähm
die, wenn man das jetzt zu Ende denkt, Schritt für Schritt äh irgendwann dann eben schon.
Bei der nuklearen Eskalation enden kann, wenn man das das eben logisch weiter verfolgt.
Ähm da ist.
Glaube ich, wichtig äh sich zu vergegenwärtigen, äh dass sagen auch so eine Eskalationslogik oder Eskalationsspirale jederzeit,
auf jeder Stufe stoppen kann.
Und das ist das normalerweise äh auch auch tut, weil äh sich ich sage mal bei so einer Eskalation.
Überanstrengen sich beide Seiten
auch unter Umstände oder oder strengen sich halt dann äh sehr an, verausgaben sich wie auch wie auch immer und.
Müssen dann erstmal runterschalten um zu regenerieren
nennt sich dann irgendwie eskalieren, um zu deeskalieren. Das heißt, man treibt's hoch
und alle dann sagen, okay und jetzt äh ja jetzt brauchen wir beide erstmal etwas.
Ruhe. Ähm so. Das ist sagen das das eine Ding.
Ähm das ist jetzt allerdings auch nicht nicht zwingend. Ich muss sagen, es ist aber genauso wenig zwingend, dass es jetzt immer äh weiter eskaliert. Im Moment allerdings.
Ja gesehen haben äh geht das bei den Russen nicht ganz so schnell mit dem jeweils mit den
Antworten, wenn wir mal von ausgehen, dass sie jetzt die das ihre Antwort jetzt auf die äh äh Offensive jetzt vier Wochen gedauert hat. Ähm.
Dann äh ja äh und es gibt halt jetzt Treffen, gerade heute wohl irgendwo Putin trifft seinen Sicherheitsrat,
den Weißrussland irgendwie passieren ja auch noch Dinge äh äh gerade und
Jedenfalls wollen sie sich irgendwie jetzt gerade über die weiteren Schritte jetzt beraten. Das heißt, äh ja, es kann sein, dass jetzt dann vielleicht,
ja Eskalation äh äh kommt aber erst.
Wieder einer gewissen Verspätung, bis sich das bis sich die Russen da irgendwie sortiert haben und und wissen was sie denn da noch eskalieren können oder wollen. Ähm.
Zur Frage jetzt der nuklearen Eskalation und das das das nuklearen Risikos wird auf der einen Seite.
Ist es durchaus real und sich das jetzt auch ganz viele Leute irgendwie Experten.
Angeguckt und irgendwie Papers darüber geschrieben grade und und Artikel und das Haarklein auseinandergenommen aber.
Ende ähm läuft's auf die Frage äh raus so äh.
Würde Putin das machen oder nicht. So würde er sagen den den Schritt.
Gehen. Ähm ganz unabhängig jetzt von.
Sage mal, Nützlichkeitserwägungen oder so oder was dann passiert, sondern einfach ähm.
Ja äh hat er hat er den Mumm äh äh dazu und da.
Gab's da ein sehr interessantes Statement von dem bereits erwähnten Redenschreiber von Putin, der meinte, also Putin sei ihm in der Zeit jetzt nicht besonders durch persönlichen,
Mut aufgefallen, sondern eher dadurch, dass wenn es irgendwie.
Persönlich äh hätte an die Wäsche gehen können. So dass er da eher einen Schisser äh äh war, ja und dass er schon eigentlich sehr gerne leben möchte. So,
und äh dass uns seine Einschätzung ist äh dass Putin äh bisher zumindest immer.
Wenn es nur sagen ihm an die Wäsche ging äh äh quasi den
gekniffen hat. So das ist jetzt, heißt jetzt nicht zwingend, dass das jetzt diese Einschätzung korrekt
ist oder dass Putin nicht irgendwie sich geändert hat in der in der Zeit oder so, aber das ist zumindest eine Einschätzung, die sich interessanterweise mit einer meiner sehr frühen Einschätzungen vor.
Monaten zu Kriegsbeginn quasi und sagen, was ist denn das Psychogramm von von Putin?
Und äh dann gesagt hatte, ja äh fast alle Mafia-Bosse
äh sind auch nicht also kaum ein Mafia-Boss ist irgendwie im Kugelhagel äh äh jetzt gefangen genommen worden. Es gab dabei Escobar bei seiner zweiten Flucht eine kleine Ausnahme, aber.
Normalerweise haben die sich halt dann alle ergeben, das heißt
äh ist halt in der Realität nicht so wie im Film, dass die Mafia Bosse jetzt grade die
die die allermutigsten äh sind persönlich. Und ich meine, man hat's ja bei Putin auch so ein bisschen gesehen, wie er covid
gehandelt, hat damit,
äh den exzessiven Abständen und so, also ja das ist so bestätigt so ein bisschen die Einschätzung, dass er einfach nicht sterben möchte und wahrscheinlich
eher dann wenn's zu der Situation kommt, dass er nicht mehr
weiter weiß, dass er dann eher äh zurücktreten,
wird äh und irgendwie einen Nachfolger vorschlagen wird, der dann übernehmen soll und dass es sozusagen seine.
Dass das wahrscheinlichste.
Also Putin ist ein Schisser, der läuft nur. Na gut, das ist doch mal ein positiver Ausblick Pavel.
Das ist äh ja und äh wie gesagt und.
Besser als Atomkrieg.
Ja ja und ähm so und es gibt halt zunehmend eben wohl auch ganz klare äh Signale auch aus äh Indien und auch äh aus China äh das.
Ja äh die.
Nicht damit einverstanden wären, wenn wenn Russland das das täte. So, also das ist noch mal ein ein weiteres Ding.
Aber wie gesagt, das sind alles Aspekte am Ende. Es ist eine Frage, sagen wir's, wofür entscheidet sich Putin,
letztlich und äh ja und Putin will nicht sterben. So, das ist vielleicht äh äh.
Ja.
Gut lass uns hier zum Ende äh kommen, sonst wird das alles wieder viel zu lang.
Okay. Ja, wir sind hier.
Ja Leute, ich hoffe unsere Einschätzung konnten euch äh wieder weiterhelfen.
Ja und wir werden sehen,
jetzt die nächsten ein, zwei Wochen äh werden dann nochmal viel darüber verraten, welchen Weg das Ganze jetzt nimmt und ich rechne im Moment eher sich mit so sechzig Prozent, dass es sich
eher jetzt etwas beruhigen wird mit 40 Prozent Eskalationspotenzial. Das heißt äh ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich auch nicht. Damit entlassen wir euch. Bis bald. Tschüss.